so we have this amazing game called the
story engine and that's going to help us
generate an idea we're going to use your
tools to develop the idea into a movie
okay we'll start by drawing a card
there's different cards the first one is
the agent card presumably that's the
protagonist so we have a an automaton a
machine a puppet and a
servant okay interesting yeah what of
the four which one do you think would be
the best to build a story
around
well an automaton is certainly
timely and it is a machine and it can be
a puppet in certain ways and it can be
certainly a servant so it en it
encompasses a lot of those elements and
yet is still open-ended and very much of
today
which of the four do you think would
actually make the least interesting
story I don't know because
there's really infinite variables in
each
one so whereas one might think a puppet
or a servant would naturally appear less
interesting there's so much potential
nuance and a servant often has much more
capability and sort of behind the
scenes facility and power than they
might appear at first puppets have been
used
in varying ways where they can
be brilliant and unexpected and
unpredictable or treacherous and you
know there's
a a really full spectrum potential in in
that too a
machine sounds more
inert because a coffee grinder is a
machine so that might be the
least the
least my brain is not exploding with
possibilities when I look at machine
whereas with each of the other ones it
just starts going my brain is just going
yeah yeah lots lots this right direction
just sort of all over the place of of a
very full spectrum of possibilities for
each
one okay I mean so we have a a servant a
puppet and do you have a a a choice of
one I mean you could be an inanimate
object or it could be a political puppet
it could be a servant uh who works in a
wealthy person's home or it could be a a
civil servant could be different types
of you know we can choose from many
different ways but well I the automaton
is the one that I think grabs me the
most because it is timely and it is a
kind of a puppet and is a kind of a
servant so it en
encompasses though and it is a machine
it encompasses all of them in a rather
rather Universal way and yet with the
onset of AI and Elon musk's automaton
and robots you know in just the general
fear of
robots and
the astonishing potential inherent in
them it's a rich Arena that
is very open-ended and kind of very
chemically active in my brain before I
even start poking it okay so it sounds
like that will be our protagonist then
the autom okay now the next step would
be to draw an engine card
all right so we have wants to stop the
theft of wants to steal or steal
from okay
interesting which scenario do you like
the
best steel is for me more
open-ended because to stop the theft
of feels more um like a normal daily
function like a good servant would
naturally be trying to stop the theft of
something
and so to steal from there
there's you know it's it's a less
predictable type of automaton the
reasoning of why this automaton is
trying to steal something all the
mechanics of that all
the what's the word for it the the
pre-programming
that might have a have a type of
prohibitive effect on the
automaton so that the automaton is like
going against internal commands or
something to achieve that you know there
there's just
it's feels a little more
Dynamic okay and open-ended if you had
to play the other scenario
how how do you think you would weave
that in with this
automaton well it's there's a full
spectrum full spectrum of
possibilities in terms of preventing the
theft of what you know so it could be
preventing the theft of a nuclear weapon
that could end the world or you know
blow up the Eastern cboard of America or
something or it could
be you know to prevent the theft of an
important artifact something of personal
value so it's like on the other end of
the spectrum and then there's everything
in between
of the theft of something that will
severely
disrupt an ongoing successful
operation or the theft of something with
tremendous emotional power that can
really disrupt
something
and
it's really just a matter of
like what you set the dial to the
intensity the
stakes is going
to
motivate the way in which this
automaton Works to prevent the
theft excellent so it could be riveting
from beginning to end because the whole
fate of the world hangs on it or it
could be intensely personal and it's you
know making sure this kid's doll doesn't
get taken because that's the end of the
universe for that particular kid so you
just find the context and then find a
way to give it magnitude make it matter
to the audience and some of them are
naturally more nail-biting than
others and what if we had to choose both
what if we incorporated both scenario
well that's a nice complication
because it's like a crooked cup where
you're I'm here guarding the the
whatever and while I'm doing that I'm
busy working the yeah working the back
doors to steal something much bigger in
the museum that I'm now guarding or
something there's all
those um kind of tunnels under tunnels
and how do you disguise what you're up
to and you know is the theft from good
intention or evil intention you can be
stealing something
that unless you steal it there will be a
lot of
trouble excellent okay okay so now we
have the anchor card if you would do a
SE honor please of choosing anchor card
love how this is going excited to see
how it turns out all right so we have a
hospital
a
contagion a medicine a
death which one of these would make the
most
sense in the
story a contagion is
timely with
coid but people
might kind of have coid
fatigue uh kind of sick of hearing about
it
but generally you don't
write many people suggest not writing
about topical events because quite soon
they're yesterday's news and whereas
right now you could go oh this will you
can amplify this into something but
people may be so sick of it or not care
about it 6 months from
now so the topical the topic ality of it
sets off an alarm Bell in my brain
because I kind of been trained for that
you know go for something that's still
Universal a thousand years from now
rather than it's forgotten about in six
weeks a medicine is
interesting because that can really be
world
changing
uh and not not only that but but it's
the
um there's a huge amount of money in
that
field uh they used that well in the
Harrison Ford movie The
Fugitive where the provasic was a
medicine whose uh lab tests were
falsified so they could make big money
on it a death
the death is certainly interesting you
know there can be high stakes there or
there can be no Stakes they like why
does nobody care that this person died
how come like it
doesn't bleep the radar at all or it can
be the death can be world changing and
it can be an impending death a sudden
death a death that happened 40 years ago
a death that happened last night a death
that's been threatened so there's
there's broad flexibility in each one of
these things like and I talk to my
students about this that as
we're building a script I'm always
talking about how you want to be make
tentative decisions
and be plastic as a habit of mind so
that every everything stays fluid as
long as possible
because then you're not just go okay
it's got to be this it's much better to
be well it's kind of that and then as
you work with it more you you refine it
a little bit more and you're constantly
grooming it and shaping it how you want
so when I look at something like this I
don't just see one thing I see like five
or six different possibilities all
clustered together as variables and I
can really I'm trained for that it's
like a juggler you can just a skilled
juggler can be like watching the news
and they don't miss a ball so like I can
I'm good at holding four or five
possibilities in solution as you know
options okay um so we're and a hospital
was the fourth one ah okay yeah so no on
contagion possibly the death death is
interesting medicine is extremely
interesting Hospital
is interesting it's a whole universe
unto
itself uh I come from a family of
doctors I grew up around
hospitals
[Music]
um and hospitals you know a lot of
people die in hospitals so they can get
a bad rep but a lot of people get saved
there a lot of people get born there so
even though it's easy to associate them
with failure and loss there's also a
huge element of regeneration and the
gift of life and you know all of a
sudden you're going to live 50 more
years when you might have died that
afternoon that kind of
thing it doesn't fascinate me as much as
a medicine for
instance a hospital is an interesting
setting and has a lot of possibilities
but it's finite in a certain
way
medicine I think medicine is the most
interesting and a death is the second
most
interesting okay but a death is cool
because it really is it brings in the
whole
uh the the element of like a murder
mystery or that kind of thing it it like
opens another whole hallway full of
doors as
possibilities okay great so now what
we'll do is inject conflict
okay and so we will uh draw a conflict
card all
right all right we have two here but the
innocent will suffer but it means giving
up their
dream interesting do automatons Dream of
Electric
Sheep when Philip K dick wrote do
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep I
don't know maybe 1968 I don't remember
the date but was not current AI
capabilities even though he's a science
fiction writer and he's seeing into that
but we're these things are actually real
now so the science fiction authors are
kind of
like uh working with what we have now
and then
projecting into the future from
that and so the idea that an Android
might have to give up its
dream that's really
interesting and they just said they
think they they the spiders dream that's
been on the internet
lately I know I mean it seems like our
dog dreams when he's like he's running
and barking and things
and so that's really interesting but the
innocent will suffer yeah that's
interesting too and that also speaks to
the
the programming it's not the right word
the laws of robotics which goes back to
Isam ISAC aimof
um I don't remember them verbatim but
you you will never harm a human being or
you will never allow a harm human being
to be harmed by your
inaction I don't remember the other ones
but the one of the things that I use in
my class constantly in terms of working
with dilemma and illustrating someone
trapped in a dilemma is Robbie the robot
from uh the movie Forbidden Planet 1956
or something like that which has lesie
Adams in it the comedian and he's
playing a serious space investigator uh
Spaceman and they've gone to a
Shipwrecked it's people who've been
Shipwrecked on a planet there's only two
survivors morbius and his daughter
um and morbius found some alien
technology inside the planet and using
that technology built Robbie the robot
who's extremely sophisticated robot and
he's demonstrating Robbie to Commander
Adams the lesle neelen character and he
has Robbie he he has Commander Adams
give Robbie the ray gun he orders Robbie
to shoot a tree outside he does so and
then he orders Robbie to point the gun
at Commander Adam Adams who's starting
to get pretty nervous and then he orders
Robbie to Fire and Robbie starts short
circuiting is
like and you can see the sheets of
electricity going up through him and
he's like kind of having a
meltdown and morbius
says Robbie is caught in a dilemma he's
been programmed on one hand to never
disobey my orders but he's also been
programmed to to never harm a human
being so he says if I leave him like
this will just melt down his literally
his core will melt um cuz his computer
cannot send a command in either
direction so he releases him from the
command and it's such a great
illustration of someone trapped in a
dilemma because if you have two equally
unacceptable
Alternatives and and a really obvious
one would be like a Sophie's Choice
type you know sacrifice one kid or the
other she's she like she doesn't have a
gun but she's like she can't her brain
can't send a command in either direction
and you want that even though
Sophie's Sophie's dilemma is not a
dilemma the way I teach it where it
encompasses a full proportion of the
script it's more just a story we are
told in the middle of that movie that
explains why she's
so upset that illustration of the of the
short circuiting robot is the kind of
thing you want when you create a dilemma
and the innocent will
suffer that could trigger one of the
robotic laws that the
robot not like can't allow people to
suffer because that's an unrealistic
command because there's forms of
suffering all over the place constantly
the robot couldn't move if it could
never allow suffering it would be swept
up in every single thing that came by
him but there's a certain degree of
suffering that begins to perhaps
approach death which might
trigger or
activate some of the prohibitions that
are built into this robot if that makes
sense right I think Ursa cawin has a
similar thing about suffering we are
something amous about if we knew that
everything would be okay if one child
though had to suffer and no one would
say anything about it yeah there's
there's some story that she wrote that
right and there's a lot of moral
dilemmas like that you know if you can
save this train there's 50 people on it
but that means 30 people on this train
will die there's all those types of
things um which I thought would be
useful in terms of working with dilemma
as a writer they're somewhat useful but
they're so
specialized that it's kind of like
one one aspect of studying dilemma which
hasn't been as useful as I thought it
would be and so I I know of it but I
don't mine it a
lot let's try to add some details and
we'll um add an aspect card which is the
last card
okay so we have
glorious
treacherous wish
granting and cloying cloying
means clingy or it's it's like
unpleasant I don't
remember what exactly what that word
means easy to look it
up I've heard it used perhaps in the
sense of smell where something smells
dead or something but I don't think
that's a right let me just so we yeah
let's look it up so we have the right so
the definition of cloying is disgusting
or distasteful by reason of excess like
cloying sweetness excessively sweet or
sentimental
a cloying romantic comedy her coess
grows cloying after a
while
interesting okay so
it's yeah just like too
much okay okay
interesting So
Glorious treacherous wish granting those
are the two that
well
glorious and treacherous are
interesting because as treacherous as we
saw Adolf Hitler he saw what he was
doing as glorious like he was saving the
world
so the context and the point of
view with which you look at these
things like this automaton
on could be treacherous and yet feel
like it's
doing the world a huge
service and it might be monstrous but
the robot may be programmed in such a
way that it can't see that what it's
doing is evil or wrong or ethically
questionable or that kind of thing so so
those are both very interesting and then
wish
granting is
fascinating
and
it's interesting in part because of
where quantum physics is going these
days and an automaton ability to
um manufacture like Robbie the
robot could
like morbius would give him a sample of
lead and he'd say make us 600 lb of lead
or 600 tons of lead and he just
manufactures it inside his body one of
the one of um Commander Adams's
crewmen gives the robot a sample of
whiskey and the robot says yeah yes I
can manufacture this for you with 60
gallons P sufficient and the guy's like
oh yeah that would be
great and that's a a bit of an old
school example but if a if an
automaton is tapped into some sort of
manufacturing capability 3D printers
even the ability to Jean splice and
manufacture highly specific things to
order it opens up a kind of
a how in 2001 type thing and obviously a
genie type thing but the capacity
to manifest something that was only an
idea through like state-ofthe-art
science and enhanced capacity and access
to a like if it if this robot was made
by a massive like manufacturing facility
it might have access to all of that
equipment even if it's stolen
access and like yes I could make that
happen so it's very open-ended in that
way and
suggestive but the one that jumps right
out at me is treacherous that like grabs
me by the
throat and wish granting is
like there's a lot of fun possibilities
in that it's very
open-ended and obviously
in any story that has wish granting in
it always has the caveat
of you know be careful what you wished
for like you wanted it so badly and now
you have to deal with it but that's also
I get tired of that form of wish
fulfillment stories and it's also a kind
of don't you dare think big type of
thing that Society does to people you
think big you're gonna get it which just
is like crushing people down you're
worthless you're no good and I don't
like that and so I like to go the
opposite way of like you know dare to
think big explode the boundaries don't
let them tell you you're not allowed to
be great or be dynamic
or you know not just think outside the
envelope but disintegrate the
envelope so it's interesting and it
really could these all except for
cloying
which feels outside the context in a
certain way of these things but also
while I'm not a stranger to the word
it's not part of my normal lexicon it's
not a word that just comes to
mind and I think I've read it in novels
way
where you know soldiers are Marching
through a city and
there's dead bodies everywhere and
they're saying the cloying smell
foulness filled there nostrils or
something like that like overly sweet
and weird
and so it the the few contexts that I
have for
cloying don't jump out of me at all like
these other
three I would say treacherous
treacherous and wish
granting are the ones that jump out at
me the
most okay do you feel we have enough of
the cards pulled uh to make a story or
would you like to pull an extra
card um to build more of the story
around do you feel like you have enough
here if you were to I mean there's
enough here to build a story
we're absolutely building from
scratch because these are just raw
elements and you know you could build a
a wacko comedy or you could build a
brutal thriller or anything in between
so it's very open-ended you know there's
a there's a direction because these
things infer certain possibilities and
Trigger possibilities in my
brain
um so part of me thinks well another
card would be interesting but part of me
thinks there's so there's kind of an
embarrassment of riches right here
already and throwing another thing into
the mix might just be an unnecessary
complication so so I'm really not sure
either way okay well we can always pull
a card later if if needs
be Jeff of the cards we have chosen from
the story engine Dex what do you think
the premise would be with our story here
well I'm I wouldn't know what to come up
with as a premise at this point because
it's so wide open in terms of
possibilities
and each new story idea comes to you in
a different way and sometimes there's a
premise built right into it from the
beginning like in the live training I'm
doing now with people 5 days a week week
we're building a romantic comedy and the
idea that I came up with was one of my
favorite movies which is uh my favorite
year with Peter oul directed by Richard
Benjamin it's about a drunken movie star
and this guy has to babysit him while
he's in town to be part of the Sid
Caesar show based on a true story with
Errol
Flynn um and it's a great movie Peter
otou is amazing in it and
I thought well
so if this guy has to
babysit uh this this actor it's
a and the actor is about to get thrown
out of the country so the woman who's
babysitting him kind of a corporate I
can get it done type to keep him from
getting thrown out of the country she
marries him and so it was my favorite
year meets the
proposal and I was like that's we can
have fun with with that and you can like
see the premise in it right away like
it's kind of sitting there whereas this
is more just like somebody dumped a a a
Lego set out on the
floor and you could build anything out
of it you know from like a mermaid to a
a warship to a a castle to you know a
meal it's like you could and this feels
like that
it's it's really Dynamic it has a real
kind of of Philip K dick warp to it
or no it's susceptible to having a
Philip K dick
warp incorporated into
it
um and it also reminds me
of uh the Alfred bester book The Stars
my
destination which is considered one of
the top science fiction books of all
time but but in it there's a robot
that's a bartender looks like an
1890s kind of Steampunk robot but
it's no one of the characters is
radioactive in the story and he can only
be around people for like 29 minutes at
a time and he's in the room they're
having a really high level meeting
toward the end of the story and this guy
comes in who's radioactive and they're
really getting down to Brass tax trying
to pressure the main character into
doing something
and his radioactivity sets up sets off
the robot Who's the bartender who's
serving them drinks and he the the robot
starts getting whacked out and the main
character asks poses a question to the
robot and it comes up with an
interesting
answer because of the
radioactivity so
there's there's
um dynamic possibilities in that and it
reminds me of an Alfred bester short
story called fondle Fahrenheit where
this guy has a very highlevel robot that
can paint like Michelangelo you know
write poetry like Lord Byron whatever
and like it can do anything and he can
hire it out and make great
money but something goes wrong with it
and it goes crazy and it kills a little
girl so then he has to go to a different
planet and they're looking for you know
like this super high-end robot so
he makes its capabilities less it can
still go out and make money for him but
it can't sculpt like Michelangelo
anymore because they'll find him right
away and then it kills somebody else so
he keeps going on the run with the robot
he can't enable it to do as
much and the robot it turns out is
overheating and starts doing this kind
of skitso dance where it's like dancing
AR Rumba and chanting and it's just
and so that like a a radioactive robot
or there's so
many whacked out things you can do to a
robot that it's very
suggestive you know and a robot wants to
steal
treachery a death
um
so there isn't so much like a premise
shaping up as just just one possible
kind of warped
Direction based on my own science
fiction uh Tendencies
or the things that I enjoy in a
story I think that I
would want to look at the 36 traumatic
situations for a minute because it it is
a spectrum of
possibilities the other thing is
that as I'm looking ahead to exploring
the anagram as possibilities for this
story to what
degree does an automaton
have the full spectrum of emotional
complexity that a human has and
obviously even as I'm saying that I'm
thinking well it's an AI and they can
build all that stuff in these
days
but you know does the robot have a
warped sense of the way the world works
because his father used to beat him or
something it's like at what point
does personal history not
exist or or you know and then of course
on the other hand you have the Tyrell
Corporation where Tyrell says we gift
them with memories so that they it makes
them easier to control
because they don't perceive that they're
dying in two years and they have to
fight
that they there's their emotions it says
it gives them a a
cushion um right like so all that is
possible right and in fact the better it
can be done the more potentially scary
this robot can be or more heroic this
robot could be depending and it could be
both at the same time and there you get
into the element of dilemma like is the
robot programmed secretly programmed for
treachery even while it
acts wonderful and enlightened and
polite uh like C3PO or something whereas
R2-D2 will freaking laser you into dust
if that's what it takes whereas c3p
would be like are you sure that's quite
polite or to to to vaporize that fellow
so the the
the the um
competing
commands in the robots programming and
can create an intriguing dilemma and and
the more complexity of personality and
character that the robot
has the more compelling the story can
potentially
be now we could possibly pull another
agent card if we wanted to bring in
let's say a b character and maybe some
of the moral dilemma would fall on that
character maybe because they're uh not
an AI and they they have no I would want
the I would want the Dilemma to be
to to be in the protagonist okay all
right but we still need a good strong
villain we definitely need other
players but
we're approaching this in an interesting
way that we have a handful of dynamic
elements and as and I think that the 36
traumatic situations will be useful I'll
pull that out in a minute it's things
like ambition Madness disaster
those kind of things and I think that
as some possibilities begin to
gel that will inform choices for a good
strong
antagonist in other words the story will
help Define who the best protagonist
might be and other main characters as
well we're going to tests the story that
you're coming up with from the story
Engine with the 36 dramatic situations
and anram and various things I'm
wondering should we name this
protagonist for me that would be
premature because it's so kind of
explosively open-ended at this
point
and one of my favorite points in the
development of a story is the point
where the sky the limit like any this
this story there's dozens of Poss
stories in this and I want
to kind of like play on the lava like
Superman playing in lava like just sort
of Revel in
the open-ended possibilities rather than
starting
to consolidate and the the name at one
from one point of view is like a detail
but I don't want to
restrict any of the aperture in this at
this point because the automaton could
be male it could be female it could be a
deity of A
Sort uh you know that lives inside a
machine and presents as one robot but it
really isn't just that there's so
many wildly open-ended possibilities
that I would prefer to sort of arrive at
that detail a little bit later fair
enough okay so we have your book here
correct yes okay and this is just the
list of the 36 traumatic situations
great and it's
just it was created in the 1700s by an
Italian playright named Carlo GSI it was
endorsed by Gerta and Schiller and on
the strength of those endorsements hung
around for 150 years or something until
George py turned it into a book in
1916 and it says that basically
you can describe any story quite
completely with these 36 traumatic
situations like Pursuit disaster falling
prey to Cruelty or Misfortune Revolt
daring Enterprise they're elements and
you can describe any story quite
completely from one point of view with
the 36 traumatic situations in the same
way that I can describe this table quite
completely from one point of view with
the periodic table of elements so this
table is carbon hydrogen oxygen
magnesium and so from one point of view
you can describe it quite
completely and
so let's see what I'm seeing here so
supplication asking or begging for help
is
interesting
because if we have an
automaton and the need to steal
something and a death or a
medicine and there might be treachery
involved
so could the automaton be asking or
begging for help is the automaton being
asked asked or begged for
help it's
interesting and at this point it all
just goes into The
Cauldron which is just like a bunch of
bubbling ideas that we're trying to in
which we're trying to create life in a
certain way so Deliverance rescuing or
being rescued it seems like that's what
this story would be about in a number of
ways
um you know an attempt at a
rescue it can be a physical Rescue an
emotional
rescue but a deep strong need for for
something like that then there's crime
pursued by
Vengeance has something been done that
either is a crime or can be perceived as
a
crime
um for which vengeance is sought and
crime pursued by vengeance is very
context
sensitive because someone might take
personal affront to something that is
quite harmless but they see it as a
crime against them and
they're all flared up about it where
other people would be like that's
nothing so it's
very per
perception sensitive of who sees what as
a
crime and there's all varying degrees of
crime but it indicates that something's
been done wrong and something
substantial has to be done about it
which fits in a story with these
elements Vengeance taken for Kindred
upon Kindred it's infighting getting
even with your dad for beating up your
mom for your mom upon your
dad the infighting is interesting it
suggests possibilities and could
certainly be active especially if
there's like a large corporation with
competing
interests and infighting and
opposing ethics or something like that
Pursuit very much so like in pursuit of
something especially if you're dealing
like with a
medicine or something like that like the
need to cure something but also being
pursued
by you know is this robot trying to
achieve something and there's other
people trying to stop that from
happening so
Pursuit could certainly be active in all
of this disaster number six is is you
know it certainly suggests possibilities
that would be inherent in this
idea and disaster can be like you know
the end of the
world all the way down to a bad hair day
so it's varying it's and it's again
perception driven because you know
somebody in Beverly Hills getting their
poodle dyed the wrong shade of pink can
be like a world-ending disaster for that
person
so again is like what is perceived as a
disaster so the
robot might have to prevent a
disaster and
if that robot does
that then one party in that story might
perceive the robot saving everything as
a huge
disaster in the same way that everybody
cheers when World War II ends except
Adolf Hitler for him it's a it's a
massive disaster for everybody else it's
like thank God we finally beat them that
kind of thing falling prey to Cruelty or
Misfortune you know if you're like
ordering an AI
to do something that goes against its
ethics then it's like why me why
am how did I end up being put in this
position I hate that I have to kill
somebody or disappear something or steal
something
or you know just falling prey to Cruelty
or Misfortune is pretty self-evident now
Revolt is quite interesting a rebellion
and that could be like what's going on
with the
antagonist it could be the you know the
an the Android the automaton the robot
could be leading a Revolt it can be a
secret Revolt it can be a global Revolt
it can be a boardroom Revolt where
there's only two people involved and
that'll influence the trajectory of the
company
you know is this automaton unexpectedly
sort of turning into a Robin Hood or
something um and Revolt was absolutely
at the core of Blade Runner where the
replicants are trying to undo their
four-year lifespan daring
Enterprise you know doing something bold
and adventurous goes along with
Rebellion if you're in that kind of
context
but it's interesting in terms of looking
at it looking at an an automaton who is
programmed and probably imbued with a
certain personality and character to
have a
situation Force this robot to sort of
violate their program and become more
adventurous more
daring and they may not learn that until
the end or that may be something they
have to do early on but it's it's an
intriguing it's an intriguing thing
abduction uh abduction kidnapping or
like psychologically taking control of
someone is intriguing and interesting
the Enigma the riddle the mystery you
know if this robot is being
told to accomplish something and yet the
robot suspects the ethics of the person
who gave that command
um than the riddle of like isn't this
wrong or why is part of me like know
it's wrong and part of me knows I have
to do it and doesn't question it at
all you know so is it like potentially
the formation of a conscience in a robot
that was designed to not have one even
if it's like a a perfect Warrior that
like you say kill that it just kills
that but if it begins to grow a
conscience because of the way it's being
tortured by its master or whatever like
you have to violate your ethics to
achieve my
goal then as part of the robot's like
absolutely and part of the robot's like
I didn't even know I could question that
and I can't let my master know that but
part of my brain is like something's
wrong with this so the Enigma
like what's really going on who's really
up to what
and
then the internal mechanics of the
automaton
like why am I even asking these
questions and I'm the least suited
person to sort
out the ethics of this situation because
I was designed without ethics or I was
designed with nothing but ethics part of
me supposed to think everything through
challenge everything deeply and try to
do the right
thing you can see how it's like wildly
open-ended and I'm just kind of playing
with
possibilities and it's kind of kind of
like what will happen is like which of
these jump out and grab me by the throat
the most that's probably what will
emerge as the elements with which to
form the
premise obtaining is pretty
straightforward all different types of
people are trying to obtain stuff
animosity between kin INF fighting would
be natural in this type of thing rivalry
between Kinsmen
competitiveness murderous adultery
possibly because we're dealing with a
death
um and so death can certainly come with
adultery and that might be something
that's confusing to an Android I don't
know madness madness is quite
interesting because this type of
situation seems to infer that somebody's
definitely cracked and has a substantial
agenda that is
contrary to a lot of normal societal
moral
values but is the robot going
crazy um does the robot need to go crazy
to
assert
autonomy um the situation can be
Madness uh we have fatal imprudence
doing something unwise which can have
fatal consequences but it doesn't have
to be literally fatal the less the less
um literally you take these situations
the more use you can get out of them so
fatal imprudence could be just saying
something to your spouse and you're like
oh I shouldn't have said that now here
or she'll be pissed off all day and it's
not like anything ended but it was was
fatal for the mood that day so it is all
varying degrees of
everything
um but an automaton that is programmed
to execute with an extreme degree of
capability and all
that might
still almost intentionally push the
wrong
button and set in Action a set of things
could be fatal to the
antagonist even if part of the robot is
like don't push the wrong button and the
other and it just does it where it's
like it's kind of fighting itself so
Madness inside the robot potentially too
and fatal imprudence slang of a Kinsman
unrecognized literally that means like
you stab somebody in the dark and find
out later it was your
brother but it can also be like
someone metaphorically feeling slain and
unre recognized like a dad comes home
drunk and his his little girl comes
running out and hey Daddy and the dad is
you know really out of it and it's like
leave me alone and the little girl feels
slain and unrecognized you know I'm his
little darling he never did that to me
before I really feel slain so there's so
much
metaphoric flexibility in that but the
idea of like an
automaton always being treated a certain
way by a master and then the master says
I know you've been programmed to do this
all the time but today you have to do
this and the robot could be
like why did he tell me to do that
like he knows what I've been programmed
for you know I'm an artist I'm a what
I'm a you know I'm a top medical
researcher could be anything but I was
designed to save lives and he just told
me to poison
somebody it's like you know I feel slain
and
unrecognized so there's possibilities
like that self-sacrifice for an
ideal the robot could be faced with that
self-sacrifice for Kindred to save
others all sacrificed for a
passion it's interesting you know it
reminds me of data in Star Trek who was
you know rigorously perfect in logic and
all these things and yet one of his
deepest hungers was to know what it felt
like to be human or to get a joke or
something like that cuz he was like that
doesn't make any sense why are you
laughing what is laughter you know
so all sacrificed for a passion like
dat's hunger to be human could lead him
to
sacrifice some parts of some mission to
to get a chance
to experience what it's like to be a
human for an hour or something like that
so this robot if it's really caught in
a really intense
dilemma could make certain key choices
that violate its programming break it
out of certain things open up new
possibilities the necessity of
sacrificing loved ones yeah that could
be what the robot is faced with doing
and it can go both ways does the maker
of the robot have to sacrifice the robot
to achieve his or her
end adultery I don't know crimes of Love
discovery of the dishonor of a loved one
the finding out you've been
betrayed interesting like the robot
discovers that the master has betrayed
them or the master discovering the robot
didn't obey orders obstacles to love is
certainly inherent in there and an enemy
loved that's really
interesting because that means not just
falling in love with an enemy which
happens but also respect for an enemy or
fascination with an
enemy
uh and
so if the robot is caught between like
the commands of its master and the
Intriguing aspects of like a rebel
leader who somehow begins interacting
with this automaton
and has a fascinating
argument the robot may find
itself fascinated by this enemy and
respecting the enemy maybe even growing
to love the values that the enemy brings
to the table and yet knowing full while
but that I shouldn't even be talking to
this person much less incorporating some
of their values into my operating system
system
ambition absolutely clearly if there's
like a master of this robot who has vast
Ambitions and maybe a huge corporation
and like if they can cheat this one
thing then you go from being you know a
hundred billion dollar Corporation to a
10 trillion doll Corporation and they're
willing to do whatever it takes and the
robot could be caught in the middle of
all that and the robots Ambitions like
we were talking about data wanting to be
human and one of the things here was
um what was
it it means giving up their dream like
that spe like what kind of dream might a
robot
have um you know and this this robot
could have been to Jupiter 20 times like
seeing the whole solar system like been
on fire on the surface of mercury and
been rebuilt and like all it wants to do
is like curl up with a good book in
front of a fire or lay on the beach like
it's like it wants it's done all the the
most incredible stuff it just wants a
simple little cozy moment they talk
about that in tibetan mythology about
how the gods often want to become human
they're sick of being all wise all
knowing allseeing and they just want to
be IM mortal and have like a little
house and a white picket fence and be
finite and not know everything
thing which is kind of where data was
coming from in a certain way and this
character could certainly be doing that
so ambition is kind of explosively
active in a whole bunch of possible ways
conflict with a
God works in two key ways that I see
right off the bat like the automaton is
in conflict with its Commander its boss
and there's
conflicting commands that kind of stuff
confusing commands commands that can't
be obeyed but must be and I've often
thought
the with Robbie the robot he says you
know Robbie's
like and he really can't fire but he
can't not
fire and he releases him from the
command he says if I leave him like this
he'll melt down but the model that I
work with in terms of dramatizing a
story is you put your protagonist in a
good strong
dilemma similar to like Jake in Training
Day where he can't let go of this
amazing opportunity to make Alonzo's
Squad his ambition he can't let go of
his ambition but he can't go down the
slippery moral slope that Alonzo's
leading him on because it's more and
more criminality and risk and danger so
he can't let go of his ambition but he
can't let go of his moral compass and
then that d dma comes to a critical
juncture when Alonzo tries to have him
killed in the bathtub By the Hillside
gang members and once he gets out of
that he makes a
decision about his dilemma which is I'm
taking Alonzo down no matter what and
his action is to go in there and try to
arrest him and so I often thought
that it's almost an interesting analogy
if you could get to that robot that is
short circuiting and it's like it really
can't send a command in either
direction
and I don't know what the best way to
say it is but kind of override the
operating system and tell the robot you
must decide
now and like it you know is it going to
blow up is it what's it going to do but
it's like when push comes to shove could
you make that short circuiting
robot arrive at some kind of decision
from within it
programmed architecture that type of
thing and take some kind of action which
fits which which relates to this story
because we potentially have a robot
that's really melting down between two
unacceptable commands two commands that
cannot neither one can be obeyed but
must be obeyed he can't disobey orders
but he can't harm a human being and
Robbie the
robot so conflict with a god is
interesting the robot is up against its
creator its master and
yet and that is presumably the
antagonist although not necessarily and
yet could this Commander be up against
this robot that is Godlike in its
capacity and in its linkage or hidden
linkage to all the uh capabilities of
this you know massive manufacturing
facility kind of like how or something
like that where there's
uh tremendous
capability so going up against this
robot can be risky and you're up against
sort of all
the the fails saafe mechanis mechanisms
that you built into the robot as you try
and outwit it or defeat it or overpower
it erroneous judgment making a bad
choice the robot could make a bad choice
the master there could be key wrong
choices remorse the robot could grow to
have remorse which it didn't used to
have the boss could have absolutely no
remorse the recovery of a lost
one you know gaining something back
that's been
lost um or attempting to gain a person
that's been lost even bring someone back
from the
dead um you know you know
if if there's a key death in this story
and we saw that
in uh I Robot with Will
Smith that
the character played by James Cromwell
was killed at the beginning of the story
and yet the Will Smith characters
interacting with a
hologram of the James Cromwell character
who's trying to give him Clues but it
was all pre-recorded before Jam J
cromwell's death so he keeps
saying if you want an answer to that you
ask to ask the right question so it was
all in there but he couldn't access it
until he figured out what the right
question was if someone died like say
the boss who's trying to make the robot
do a certain thing maybe is the son of
the person that actually built the robot
and the father recently died and now
this the son sort of inherits command of
the robot's operating system and is
doing things that are
counter counter to what the father would
have done and yet still fit within that
Groove so the robot still believes it
has to obey but it's like going I I I
don't like
this and so
if the
father's elements of the father's mind
or something were
computerized
or emulated by computers they did this
with expert systems a classic example
was Campbell Soup where the guy who'
been in charge of making the big Vats of
soup for 30 years was getting ready to
retire and they they created an expert
system in which he downloaded all his
knowledge and all the variables like if
it tastes too salty you know you put in
cornstarch or whatever like a certain
amount and they basically just debriefed
everything he knew so that a machine
could emulate much of his knowledge and
and some of his
instincts so that if some aspect of the
master had been and possibly even
secretly because the the old man knew
that his son might go this way so that
he may have been laying preparation
so
um the possibility that the robot is
secretly trying to like bring the
original founder back to life to some
degree for guidance or to countermand
the order or to even regenerate the
person physically like make a clone of
them and then download a mind into them
you know these are all just
Dynamic possibilities to play with and
you can see how as I'm going through the
36 I'm trying each one on like in
varying ways and different
possibilities um so recovery of a lost
one that's where that came from and then
loss of loved ones you know like maybe
the
robot brings the old man back for a
while and that really helps the robot
kind of
become more
human and have more free will like the
like the original Master might say you
can do anything you want like we
programmed all this stuff into you but
you still have tremendous latitude and
maybe I can even go in and undo some of
those deep commands like you can never
disobey maybe that maybe the founder
serves a function at a key
moment and then
you know like even if there's like a
physical person in front of him who is
the the man maybe he only lives for 20
minutes so there's still loss of loved
ones but it's enough to kind of
like free the automaton from the
perceived limits that were binding the
automaton it's the the the classic
example that psychiatrists use a lot is
um elephants when they're young like a
circus elephant to be restrained is
hooked up to a really strong chain that
you could tow a truck with and into a
really big stake in the ground and it
knows it can't get away I mean it tries
but as it grows up it gets so used to
being chained that they just put a
little 2 by two in the ground with a
piece of clothes line and the robot
still is like up that's as far as I can
go when the did I say robot I meant
elephant the the adult elephant could
you know could shred that but they're
they're trained to that and that could
be something similar to the robot and
where the original founder might say
look you you've Incorporated all these
habits into your daily life and you're
like the adult elephant that's still
restrained by a piece of clothesline you
know you you are a creature of
tremendous
power
and you're capable of
anything and
don't think small don't let your program
which is perfect metaphor for people in
the real world having tremendous
capability but believing that they're
small and worthless and easily
controlled and all that so that's an
interesting element and that was just
you know from just going through this
one complete spectrum of ideas that can
trigger
possibilities
um and we were you
know looking at each one of those
situations
kind of through the lens of all of these
combined in varying
degrees and I really like the
um and see what it is is that some of
those stuck I said some of them will
jump out and grab me by the throat like
I really like the Son and the father and
possibly the father killed the Son and
the father had more morals than the Son
and the son is going to take a
corporation worth 200 billion and make
it worth 20it 20 trillion like within 3
months but he needs the
robot you know to withhold a
medicine or create a disease create a
contagion that the medicine is a cure
for and you know a billion people die
and then they come up with the Cure and
then eight billion people each spend
$100 on and all of a sudden this
corporation's worth 8 trillion like
literally overnight on its way to being
worth 80 trillion a year from
now but who has to die for that progress
and can the
robot deal
with the ethics and make a right choice
when it's supposed to just be a robot
that just you know keeps putting the
hubc cap on the new car without anything
else so an
automaton who is a perceived as a
servant and a puppet and a machine like
you push the button and it puts the
hubcap
on wants to
steal or wants to stop the theft of both
of them are interesting because they
they infer two opposite commands
potentially um like protect or destroy
or the the founder wants the theft to be
stopped and the new one wants it to
steal or probably more interesting is
that the AI of the
founder is recommending to the robot
that it's steel to prevent the Sun from
consolidating this new
um
Empire and a
medicine going hand inand with the
contag
is interesting in terms of
um manipulating a
global
uh you know a global um
con a death is
interesting because we were talking
about how the founder died and was maybe
[Music]
murdered even a hospital is interesting
because if this is similar perhaps to
the Ty rail
Corporation
then a lot of a a per a healthy
percentage of the setting could take
place in a hospitall like corporate
manufacturing
facility and all this kind of
subterranean
access almost hidden tunnels
or underworld aspects that the robot
might be able to incorporate the
innocent will suffer yeah if it's going
to take a billion people to die of this
contagion to sell $8 trillion worth of
this medicine that they've had for
years then that's
uh that's something the robot has to
wrestle with but it means giving up
their dream well if this robot is
designed to be
extremely helpful to
humanity kind of altruistic
and yet has been counter programmed to
cause great harm or allow great harm to
happen and yet is stuck in the middle
trying
to resolve that
dilemma that could certainly like the
robot might be programmed to be so
altruistic that its dream is to have
everyone healthy happy doing well and
it's kind of simplistic but it's like
starting somewhere within the context of
the story we're playing with
here
uh like the robot's natural inclination
to
altruism is being contravened or
corrupted by the
Sun but what's on the opposite side of
that like obviously the sun cares if
there worth 8 trillion tomorrow but what
does that give the
robot it certainly opens up the
possibility for solving a whole lot more
stuff but the sun doesn't seem to have
that natural inclination to use this 8
trillion to solve world hunger almost
the
opposite so that's
interesting means giving up their
[Music]
dream and it certainly could be you know
that the robot dreams of being
human dreams of being retired at the end
of
its
sort of indentured servitude and get to
live like a person for a while or
something that may have been something
that was always promised to it or
something and then
treachery
glorious obviously the sun could be
treacherous but the robot could be
treacherous in what it does to outwit
the
Son and the father
could promote that treachery like you
got to
think around the evil of my
son CU if you don't he's going to beat
you you got to fight dirty to beat him
because all he does is fight
dirty
so I feel like I've got more of a handle
on a potential story there I don't feel
like I have a Prem yet but I feel like
we've kind of cobbled together something
that's interesting and dynamic and
has high stakes
and complexity and a dilemma of
magnitude for this
automaton an interesting Ally in the
form of the old man a potential strong
villain in the form of the
sun um so that's a good we've kind of
gotten to a platform here where we've
got something that feels much more solid
than just a open-ended set
of
possibilities um we've kind of cooked it
down a little bit and have more of a
something
there you can talk about dilemma which
is part of your tools yeah and that
would be pretty much what I go to
next because the way that I work with
dilemma is
I'm looking at
that right from the
outset in developing the story like you
can see that even as I'm playing with
this
broad array of possibilities for the
story I keep coming back to well if the
robot had been programmed to do this and
you know like what's unacceptable to the
robot and what might be equally
unacceptable and
you know how does
that how is that impacted by commands
that are given by the robots operating
system
um by the robot's sense of
morality one of my favorite quotes which
I thought about for a flickering second
about a half an hour
ago uh it's by a writer George
Saunders and he says
um character is the governing element of
life and is above
genius
and real
character is something that's very
important and mere genius is just some
other smart dude who could be completely
crazy but he's wicked smart and it's
like but he's destructive or you know
it's like it's it's just genius you know
like kind of like throw a stick and you
can hit a genius but half of them are
screwed
up you know character is is
substantial and that could be something
that the robot is really wrestling with
and I really like the the image of data
the
character who's I think it had a
positronic brain it
was absolute state-of-the-art
computer
technology built into an Android I don't
know if it synthesized human and robot
or if it's just a pure
machine but his
hunger for Humanity and curiosity
about aspects and foibles of humanity
is intriguing it was something I haven't
seen that show in many many years but I
always liked data and I remember one
show he even became human
for a half an hour in the Hol deck or
something like
that but at the end of it
all he understands what a joke is and
he's like oh that's funny even though
he's no longer in the mindset that had
him acting really like a human Spock did
that sometimes too where he would become
more like a an impulsive wild animal
than a rigidly controlled
logician and he'd you know go into these
different states and be goofy and wacky
and funny and all that
stuff so just in terms
of focusing on trapping this automaton
in a dilemma of magnitude a dilemma that
m to the
audience there's a lot of raw material
for that
here
and it seems as
though there might be altruism on one
side like it's unacceptable to give
up a sense of what's right of doing the
right thing of being able to be
capable of
doing really
powerful world changing
things someone who's kind of like was
raised to be a brain surgeon and like
they're really trying to do good for
people
and that's built into who they are
and
why they
operate
so that's an
interesting thing to kind of just sit
there and let it float like the need to
do good a moral compass and even just a
moral
compass knowing what's right and what's
wrong
um so then to countermand that or to be
the opposite of that but equal because
you want equally unacceptable
Alternatives that's where you get that
Robbie the robot short circuiting in
between two things if
one if one side of the of the Dilemma is
more unacceptable than the other then
you have a path of least resistance and
electricity will always take the path of
least resistance but if you have equal
resistance then you block it you have
impedance and it heats
up uh in
electricity
so I know what this automaton looks like
caught in this
dilemma because it looks literally like
Robbie the robot short
cirking like it can't it's
like unable to process
command and so I know that I want to
achieve that but it's a question of what
are
the two Alternatives that are
being sort of not just posed to this
automaton but sort of foed onto this
automaton forced like Sophie's Choice
it's not like oh that'll be a fun Choice
which kid do I sacrifice it's horrible
it's it's like I don't want any of
this but it may it may not be that
extreme but we want something
substantial of magnitude that really
impacts an
audience and you want not only magnitude
a dilemma that matters to the audience
but you want it to
where the audience can relate to it
personally and
that's an important aspect of working
with dilemma because if
you're trapping a protagonist in a
dilemma
and the average person in the audience
can understand it
intellectually but has no emotional
connection to it then they're like I see
what they're talking about but I don't
care so one of the questions I'm always
asking my students is once you have a
dilemma trapped between two equally
unacceptable
Alternatives can the average member of
the audience connect to that and so what
I say is like you know pick somebody who
like lives down the street that you
don't even know and sort of study them
indirectly you know they might be
someone who's like you know a graduate
student in dance and really creative and
drives Uber at night to make ends meet
and it's just a regular person down the
street so you've got your character
trapped in this dilemma can that person
down the street that you don't really
know or don't know at all can they
connect to that or is it like because
you want your average member of the
audience who's just a plumber taking his
kids to the movie or whatever do they
see themselves in it because if they
don't then they're less connected to it
and they say that the deeper you go the
more Universal you
get
so if the movie you know is about you
know a contractor in France who's caught
up in a tricky
situation
it should be so that like you know a
doctor in Australia can watch that movie
and go I don't know anything about
building houses but his dilemma of like
Duty versus honor or something like that
like I can totally relate to that so
it's
like what we want as
we work with developing a dilemma for
this automaton is to make it so that the
average member of the
audience looks at that dilemma and goes
wow I'm caught in the same dilemma it's
a different set of circumstances but I'm
caught in that exact same thing and I
don't know how to get out of it maybe
this robot can solve the thing that's
paralyzing me in a fundamental way then
the audience cares that much more and
it's a visceral connection it's an
emotional connection not just an
intellectual understanding it's
interesting to try to trap this robot in
a real quandry they do a decent job of
that in the Will Smith movie I Robot
Will Smith hates robots because they
tore off his arm at one point he's a
cop the head of this huge corporation
gets thrown off a 30 story
landing and we'll Smith is brought in to
investigate and everybody thinks this
robot killed the
master but and Will Smith hates that
suspect robot from the beginning because
he's prejudiced against all robots he
hates them all but he begins to perceive
that the robot that is under
suspicion has unique insights and
is the total opposite of what he thought
um and it's and that robot was actually
reprogrammed by the old man before he
was killed and that robot is there to
help Will Smith stop the robot
Corporation from doing something
treacherous I don't remember exactly
what it was I think it's a robot army
that they're unleashing on the World to
control
them but it's interesting
because
because that
robot is either raising interesting
questions in Will Smith's mind or Will
Smith is Raising interesting questions
in the robot's
mind I can't recall but that's just a
movie I've seen that has similarities to
this type
of potential story
and like I can feel the presence of the
Dilemma even if I'm not able to
articulate it clearly at this point
because I'm still kind of inventing what
these two equally unacceptable
Alternatives could be but I
know I know how that robot feels trapped
in that type of
situation I have an emotional connection
to what that does to this
robot
and so as I sort of try to conjure what
these things might
be it can be helpful to look ahead to
the point of Crisis where the Dilemma
comes to a critical juncture around the
three quarters point in the movie around
the end of act
two because we want the Dilemma to kick
in somewhere around the end of act one
where we've we've gotten to know the
main character the story's developed and
as as the story gets up to speed like
the full complexity of the story is All
kicking in we want this robot to be
trapped in this dilemma of magnitude
either before the end of act one or by
the end of act one and we want that
Dilemma to extend throughout act
two where the Dilemma goes
critical prior to that the robot is like
I can't pick in either direction and the
same with jayoy in Training Day I can't
let go of this opportunity but I can't
do what Alonzo is trying to get me to
do uh and
so that dilemma is going to go critical
around the end of act
two and then the protagonist has to make
a
decision about the dilemma and take an
action about it
it now that it's gone critical and then
the ending of the story is the
resolution of the Dilemma the active
resolution of the Dilemma by the
protagonist that conclusively resolves
the Dilemma so the Dilemma is like fully
engaged before the end of act one or
around the end of Act One it builds an
intensity all throughout act two to the
point where it reaches this critical
juncture that forces the protagonist to
make a decision an taking action about
the Dilemma that he or she couldn't
previously decide about and then the end
is the resolution of the Dilemma so the
Dilemma
encompasses most of the proportion of
the script it's not something that
happens for five minutes in the story
it's something
that takes up most of the story and if
you look at the movie um almost most
famous by Cameron Crow he won best
screenplay for that he said
the the kid who's the
reporter he
said
he he re he can't become friends with
the band because then he's no longer an
objective
reporter and if he does become friends
with them they'll try to make him write
about how cool they are so he he loves
this band it's unacceptable to not
become friends with them cuz they're the
coolest creatures around and he's uncool
so he's desperate for that and yet his
mentor the Philip seamour Hoffman
character says do not become their
friend because they'll make you into a
puppet and write about how great they
are you want to be an objective reporter
and really stick to your guns on that
and Cameron Crow said that dilemma is
what the movie is about and if you look
at it again you can see that constitutes
the full proportion of the script it
takes a little bit of time of setup to
get just get to know him he gets in with
the band starts traveling with him but
after he's really in there he has great
opportunities to become friends with
them but he really wants to be a good
reporter so the Dilemma
is constitutes much of the proportion of
the script and the way I describe it
sometimes is like it's like a whale in
your living room it doesn't take up
every square inch but it takes up the
full thing you can still walk around it
and stuff but it's not a little thing in
the middle of your living room it's the
Dilemma is constitutes the full
proportion of the
script so all of that to say that as I
work to conjure what these two equally
unacceptable Alternatives could be that
paralyzed the protagonist for much of
the
script one way
to
um see what these might be more more
clearly is to look ahead to the point of
Crisis like okay so at some point this
dilemma is going to come to a make or
break point which is very much the gun
to the head on the protagonist like you
don't get to spend any more time
thinking about how you're going to what
kind of decision you're going to make
about this dilemma you have to decide
now that's the nature of a crisis it
demands immediate decision and
action and so
sometimes looking ahead to what the
crisis might look like can help you see
what this is by sort of looking through
the opposite end of the telescope or
seeing it from a different point so if
I'm this robot and I'm trapped and I can
really feel these things I just don't
know exactly what they are yet and
that's okay but at some
point there's going to be a make or
break crisis about this dilemma
yeah and it's really about morality like
versus ambition I think like if the son
of the leader is going to make 8
trillion
overnight I can see the
robot feeling
morality but does a robot have that type
of
ambition like does it care about 8
trillion I don't know I mean like I have
13-year-old girls and they're very aware
of money now and like it and are
interested but you know when they're
eight you know they get Christmas money
or and we' like put it on their desk and
they like didn't pay any attention to it
we'd find it like you know under a book
the next week or they just they didn't
it didn't mean anything to them yet so
like to what degree might an
automaton value
this massive amplification of power and
possibility and all
that and certainly if it's an
AI then it could certainly have been
imbued with characteristics of the owner
that growing the company is really
important and is important to the
survival of the business even survival
of the autom
if the business gets shut down then
maybe the plug gets pulled on the autom
on the
automaton but it seems as though
like
being raised by the owner programmed or
created I don't know if the money is as
important as the capab
ility you know so is the is the
sun telling the robot
look some people are going to die in the
process of this or maybe the robot comes
back and says you know this plan you're
putting in place a whole lot of people
are going to
die and you know maybe the robot hadn't
really connected that yet and the owner
is like well yeah but that you know
that's how progress is often
made and the thing is that if our
company achieves this
Monopoly then our capability to help so
many more people and in other words
appeal to the altruism of the robot or
the moral compass or something like that
is possible and you can see I'm just
kind of feeling my way along with
it and you know I'm not even sure what
an ambitious robot even looks
like uh but it's programming it's
compulsion it's you know like more not
so much more is better but more enable
Ables more function more capability
more
something it's puzzling like I'm not
sure
so but so I'm not exactly sure what the
crisis is but I can see a sense of what
decision and action in the face of
Crisis might look like because the par
the the crisis breaks the paralysis of
the
Dilemma it forces a decision and
action and they say uh aristole said
that decision and action in the face of
Crisis reveals the true character it
strips the mask off you like you don't
know who your real friends are until
you've been through a crisis with them
the classic example is the big strong
guy jumps up and runs out screaming the
little guy jumps up and saves the day so
you don't know what people are really
made of until they're forced by a crisis
to show what they're really made of and
I could see the robot really trying to
do the right thing at the point of
Crisis but to get to the resolution
which is the resolu the conclusive
proactive resolution of the Dilemma by
the
protagonist once
the robot takes a stand to try to do the
right thing at the critical moment then
he's got to fight to the finish with the
sun to get through the last 15 minutes
of this movie in a real knockdown drag
out fight that the robot May well
lose
uh and there could certainly be a
creative resolution for the a tomaton
but it's going to have to grow
and think differently
and disobey key things and cleave more
closely to key things some values that
it's been programmed to Value to to you
know uphold will be shattered and some
values that it's been programmed to want
will be amp ified as the way the way
people do in real life
so the one thing that's really
crystalline is decision and action I can
see the robot is really going to try to
do the right
thing
um so does that
inform what the Dilemma consists
of let me just sure and I just thought
of something too that might be driving
the son aside from money and that is
notoriety and fame that will come with
the you know and he's the the the son of
this sort of brainchild and then you
know he's the you know maybe social
media wasn't around when the father was
building the company and now maybe the
son is not 30 yet and now he'll be the
you know successful 30 under 30 and so
there's all this U you know press that
he wants and that's also driving him
yeah you know which is also kind of
Madness and sure that kind of stuff the
narcissism and the the need for power
and maybe the father was never around
because he was just working 19 hours a
day and the kid has a you know a sort of
out of proportion need to be loved or to
impress or to be
validated maybe yeah his whole identity
was um I mean I growing up in the Bay
Area I knew people that they're children
were you know from
someone's owned a tech company and that
was the first thing out of their mouth
and and you know wasn't always the
healthiest Dynamics but it was high and
my father was so and so and I think
that's a very real thing and
unfortunately it just happens absolutely
so uh you know maybe he needs that it's
driving him and also the social media
accolades and the press to be in all the
financial papers as yeah absolutely yeah
you know and we want to build complexity
into that but that's where the anagram
is so useful to dimensionalize that sun
in a way where you understand the Sun
but you still see him as a monster but
he still has very interesting aspects
and
um you know you
see upand cominging business owners who
are really ruthless with their
competitors and then after they make it
big they're like giving money away to
everybody but they destroyed multiple
businesses to get
there so it's like you
know again it's the the ambition versus
moral compass type
thing
now the other interesting model for
dilemma to try
on is something that comes
from my knowledge of of
Tootsie which is
that Michael dorsy is a a male actor
who's very talented actor but a huge
pain in the ass to work with and
he's
really inept at relating to women
um and when he dresses up as a woman and
gets
hired all of a sudden he's got a career
a fat paycheck respect as an
actor and relationships with women that
he wasn't capable of doing as Michael
now that he's Dorothy and he sees women
from a totally different point of view
now that he's Dorothy and he becomes
Dorothy becomes a crusader for women's
rights whereas Michael was kind of the
person she'd be crusading
against
so and and there's all kinds of ways in
which becoming Dorothy is disrupting m
's life in both major and minor ways
so Michael can't let go of Dorothy
because it's the best thing that ever
happened to him but he can't keep being
her because it's the worst thing that
ever happened to him and it kind of
cooked down to like Dorothy is creating
him like literally making him a better
person and destroying him like kind of
taking him apart as all these things
happen so I'm like I want to like try
that on for a possibility for this
automaton is there a way that this
situation is offering a lot
of potential
upscale to the robot and yet is also
destroying now here's something that
could
actually drive a robot or give a robot
ambition so
what
if we talked about the possibility of
the robot
regenerating the old man in humanoid
form even if it only is 20
minutes based on sneaking around to use
the equipment in the in the
manufacturing facility kind of like you
know the tyell corporation where they
can make people
um could the
Sun tell the
automaton stick with me and help me pull
this off we'll make 8 TR trillion
overnight will be worth 80 trillion this
time next year and we'll be getting up
towards a quadrillion in five years like
boom
like we can now move on to the master
plan of
actually
genetically building people so you the
automaton could have a human body and
actually walk around and get cut and
have Bo and go surfing and you know get
sunburned like all the things that
you've always wanted see that's
something that could really like the
robot is like I want that and almost
like an out of proportion irrational
like I'm desperate to have that
nothing's going to make me let go of
that but I'm also being asked to look
help execute a billion people with this
contagion so that we can sell the cure
for
it and that's going to make me human and
so see how I was like I was feeling
around for how can a robot be ambitious
what does he care about does money mean
anything at all to him but that like
that's
something and it's you know it's
Pinocchio you know the the wants to be a
real boy
um and it Taps into
data
and it doesn't have
to it doesn't have
to it doesn't have to come from a place
that necessarily makes sense from the
outside so it's not you look at that
from outside and be like no that's way
more killing a billion people is way
more unacceptable than not becoming
human but if we're dealing with like
Madness to some
degree this outsized hunger in this
automaton to be human that it's
irrational but it's EX extremely real
for this automaton and is a really deep
need that really drives this
machine that probably has a
soul a conscience
or a
personality soul is such an ambiguous
word but
um something that might emulate human
personality quite well so it's not
missing that but it wants a human
body quite a lot and the sun could
even
influence the automaton operating system
like with a virus that makes it like
more greedy to be human sort of take
that
irrational Drive
andamp ify
it
um see now there's see how I was like
I'm not sure what these are there's
something there's one of them right
there
and yes it's a real challenge to like
for this one main creature that we like
and are rooting for to really want that
we can we can get behind that but when
we look at
it becoming human versus helping kill a
billion people where it has to be
handled right so that we keep rooting
for this
Android uh because
if if the Android starts going hum Diddy
I can't wait to kill a billion people
and eat hot dogs on the beach we're like
I'm not rooting for this creature
anymore you know it's like you have to
get the audience sympathy or I think the
better word is empathy because it's not
like pity sympathy infers pity but
audience empathy like they're really
rooting for this character you have to
get the audience empathy and keep
it you can get it and then lose it if
you don't handle it right so this has to
be handled
right so that the need to become
human has some kind of
perceived equalness in the mind of this
automaton
based on this automaton skewed
perception of the
world
um like think of all the things you can
do in a body first of all maybe that
body won't age you know we're going to
put you in a body but 400 years from now
it'll still be 27 and you'll still be
the the best surfer on the beach and
like whatever and you can be brain Sur
you you can you can change the face you
were designed to change the face of
humanity even you know and these billion
people who are going to die they're
already starving they're not going to
live that much longer they're sickly
they're in you know it's
like the more
that the sun can
amplify the capabilities of this AI put
in a human body that can you know last a
thousand years versus the fate of these
people who were already going to die
anyway it's like it's like getting
somebody with terminal cancer and
sending them in as a suicide bomber it's
like there's people that will sign up
for
that so if he has to sacrifice people
that are demonstrably not going to live
that long anyway then and he's like I
can help the other seven billion people
who really need my capabilities as a
master healer
10 years from now and I've really
Incorporated so much more with with all
the wealth that this company can
do then you begin to it's not like so
wildly uneven from this automaton point
of view even though we can still go
don't be an idiot you're still killing a
billion people but I think that's also
what he's going to discover at the point
of Crisis like that the sun's been
radically lying to him or something like
that or the
you know the old man who's back as a
human for 20 minutes or whatever is like
he's lying his ass off to you just like
he always did to me he's a monster don't
let him get away with this and then
maybe you know the son comes in and
kills the father again like right who
knows but
um we have now the elements of a
dilemma that have to be managed
right
but the Deep hunger to become
human and be a savior in many ways like
an an Intelligence on an order of
magnitude Beyond any human that ever
lived in a human body that I mean I
obviously if you like you know you can
chainsaw it in half but it's not going
to die from a cold or age or those kind
of
things and it's it's interesting and it
goes back to the
um the trick of how they catch monkeys
in the Philippines which is that they
take a coconut Hollow it out make a hole
the size of a monkey's hand and put rice
inside it tie it to a tree the monkey
comes along reaches in there and grabs
the rice but holding the rice it can't
get its hand back out and the way they
catch it is they just walk up to the
monkey and grab it and it's screaming
its head off it wants to run but it will
not let go of the rice like
this Android is like I want life it's
just like what Roy baddy says to Deckard
I want more life
father um so that's
interesting and if the Android has been
infected with a virus by the
Sun that weakens
its moral compass its ethics
it's
then there's more gray area and less
black and white inside that Androids
ethical Choice
system like where it's starting to agree
with the sun yeah you know I could see
where 300 million of those people are
literally going to be dead in a week
anyway so that doesn't mess up my
Android conscience and you know it's
like he's he's able to
rationalize which is weird to say for a
robot but the more human they become the
more they get better at rationalization
I don't remember what movie it
was might have been Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang like did you ever try to go a day
without a
rationalization something like that that
it's key to how people operate and from
my own study of Hamlet which I was
trained on um the thing that I found
about Hamlet the more I studied it
was that there was a huge discrepancy
between what he says he's going to do
which is everything and what he actually
does which is virtually nothing is what
gets him and the whole royal family
killed because his the ghost of his
father says your uncle killed me go kill
him and make things right and Hamlet
who's a Crown Prince who's been raised
as a man of action that comes right to
the front he says Absolutely I'll go
kill him no problem but then the more he
thinks about it he's like was that a
trick of the devil and he's off
at College studying philosophy chasing
girls sword fighting riding horses he
has an ideal life and he's like do I
really want to give all that up to kill
my uncle and become king and be stuck in
this cold castle with all these shallow
backstabbing people around and so when
it comes time to take action he's not
sure if he should and he lets the chance
go by him and then then he beats up on
himself he's like oh I should have just
done it all right so next time next
chance boy am I going to do it and then
he doesn't do it again but he is asking
all the right
questions but the next chance he gets to
do it he doesn't and then he's really
angry he's like okay now next time watch
out I'm going to go crazy I'm really mad
now nothing's going to stop me and he
screws up yet again and so the
discrepancy between what he says he's
going to do which is everything and what
he actually does which is practically
nothing comes down to his ability to lie
to himself it's about self-deception cuz
he believes it when he says next time
I'm really going to do it but he's lying
to himself and the more I studied Hamlet
the more I grew to hate him because he's
really a screwup like literally a royal
screwup and he's unable to take decisive
action in the face of an emergency and
that's why the whole family ends up
dying but his self-deception is the
mechanism by which he does that and
everybody has self-deception in varying
degrees and the more that I studied
Hamlet and the more I grew to hate him
because I see him as an abject screwup
who can't communicate honestly with
himself so if I notice like oh I'm
talking about I'm doing this and doing
this but I'm not actually doing it I'm
like I'm doing a hamlet so get rid of
the crap and just do it or whatever but
be honest with
yourself and
so it brings up an interesting question
of like
self-deception in a robot as it becomes
more human it's able to lie to itself to
help itself get where it needs to it's
like a negative aspect of becoming
human so that's intriguing and it's a
it's an interesting dynamic in the story
and something that the sun might be able
to amplify by the introduction of a
virus that's sort of corroding or
corrupting his
rigid ethics like Robbie the robot
cannot disobey an order and cannot harm
a human being you know if one of those
things was being corrupted then maybe
sort of could disobey a command or
something like that it's it's an
interesting thing to play
with so we still don't have a whole lot
of particulars yet but we have a whole
lot more than we did 45 minutes
ago and the 36 traumatic situations just
like as I looked at ambition I'm like
so obviously
the sun who we may not have invented by
that at that point the sun could be
extremely ambitious 8 billion 8 trillion
dollar overnight what's not to like and
all that stuff and could the robot have
ambition and how does a robot have
ambition
and you know what are the Ambitions of
the founding father or something like
that but you could see how just thinking
about an automaton need to steal
medicine
innocent will suffer treachery and Glory
wish
granting looking at ambition through the
lens of th lenses of
those raw
elements gave rise to several
possibilities and really there was you
know hundreds of possibilities in on in
that but several about ambition jumped
right out and grabbed me by the throat
ambition by the protagonist the
automaton or ambition by the central
villain the Sun and that gave
us like something to actually grab onto
instead of just smok in a bucket where
there wasn't really anything you could
grab yet now we're beginning to have
some things out of which you can Cobble
together a story and we've gradually
been possibilities have been jelling a
few things have started to really
solidify decision and action even kind
of crystallizes like I can really see
that as a hard real thing I don't know
what the resolution might
be I'm getting more of a sense well now
that we have the possibility of him
becoming human and he's like
irrationally over attracted to
that that can counterbalance the
unacceptability of sacrificing a billion
people who are going to die anyway in
other words it's the ability to lie to
yourself and the virus makes him more
manipul and less rigid you know it's
like when Spock you know gets some alien
fungus and he's laying around like he's
on catnip instead of going that's not
logical you know so we're like playing
with interesting things and creating
plot devices
like corrupting part of the robot's
operating system with a
virus makes certain things that we're
trying to do more tangible and
doable rather than I wish we could had a
way to corrupt his operating system that
kind of thing what's next I'm really
liking how Dynamic this story is and
how it's it's loaded with possibility in
in a really fun
way and it made me
curious
uh there's
this thing that's similar to like a
tarot reading that's called the Sabian
Oracle that works with the Sabian
symbols um and you get like a little
mini reading from
it uh it was somebody who sat down in
the 19 an astrologer sat down in the
1920s with a psychic and held up 360
cards one degrees two degrees and she
saw an image for each one and he
recorded them so you like focus on a
question trigger it it's the same thing
in Tarot you think about a question and
then pick some cards and you get some
kind of reading from it and this is not
something I'm
into it's do it a few times a year out
of curiosity sometimes it's not worth
much sometimes it's really
interesting and so just for a story
that's this kind of partially formed
with a lot of interesting
potential I thought it would be just
curious to see
what
uh what comes up for it
wonderful
so so really I just want to like Focus
for a minute on what I'm
actually
questioning
and this would be the intention of your
story the protagonist Journey it's more
like a
question and like so as
I'm focusing I'm find myself in the
position of the Android like I'm being
the
robot and kind of like looking at the
world that now confronts me probably the
Sun and in my confusion about the
contradictory
elements it's almost like you know
what is this I'm not sure
if I'm not sure if I'm vocalizing it
right but almost like what is this story
about and I'm seeing it from the point
of view of this like confused
robot the site is what is the URL of the
website okay so here's what it
said a nature spirit dancing in the
midst of a
waterfall that's what this psychic
that's the image she saw a nature spirit
dancing in the midst of the waterfall
and then there's like an interpretation
so I'm just the image doesn't do a lot
for me right away but I'm curious the
paragraph below it what that says it
says this symbol shows skipping lightly
over the surface of Life dancing and
playing you may feel emotionally light
and almost mischievous the worries of
life and the deeper parts of your
feelings are ignored as you effortlessly
flit over the surface of any
troubles whilst this is essentially a
beautiful symbol of Joy Harmony and a
lightness of being there may be an
element of feeling cut off from your
body or reality this can lead to a sense
of alienation or difficulty in knowing
where to land or evading Problems by
ignoring them or Rising above them
effervescent Spirits dancing and a care
fore manner water and fun Peter Pan
attitudes celebrations of the natural
world waterfalls Mist nymphs fairies
subtle
energies
irresponsibility the avoidance of real
situations not taking anything seriously
escapism moving or flying around
perceptions of light fear of dark places
naive so that's interesting in terms of
this robot and and what's interesting
about it
is we talked about the sun corrupting
the operating system of this kind of
like Super Robot
for lack of a better word
um and we talked about like seeing Spock
like on catnip where he's like rolling
around on the floor laughing
and like this reminds me of that and it
kind of amplifies that
aspect of this story in an interesting
way in other words it's just a wh if
it's it's kind of like the 36 dramatic
situations like I'm looking at ambition
and it triggers a lot of Poss
possibilities as I'm looking at this
like the image itself a nature spirit
dancing in the midst of a waterfall I
was like I don't know what that means
didn't really like grab me but the
explanation is
great um feeling emotionally light and
almost mischievous that's an interesting
word the worries of life and deeper
parts of your feelings are ignored as
you effortlessly flit over the surf
surface of any troubles it's almost like
this the son has like gotten him high on
crack or something like he's like this
robot that's usually like that's not
logical we shouldn't do that like really
organized efficient on top of things is
all of a sudden like I want to look at
the little birdie and can we wrestle you
know it's like just kind of deliberately
like had a wire snipped by the new owner
to make it more malleable and yet it's
also
plays into um well it talks about the
element it says while this is
essentially a beautiful symbol of Joy
Harmony and a lightness of being there
may be an element of feeling cut off
from your body or
reality which is interesting for a
robot cut off from reality is one thing
cut off from your body is another but it
really is like a personality
change
and yet it seems great like you're
happier you don't care about logic
anymore you know like Spock wants to
play the guitar instead of you know do
Quantum calculations or
something um this can lead to a sense of
alienation or difficulty in knowing
where to land see that's the thing of
like I used to be super clear about
ethics and and how to navigate certain
types of things and now I'm
like it reminds me of the what was it
um the the killer robot movie from years
ago
um
Robocop and uh at one point toward the
end of the movie The RoboCop is trying
to go down a set of stairs but it can't
do stairs the way and it comes up to the
and it's like toes are like trying to
like it's trying to like how do you do
this like it and it fell down the stairs
but the idea of like trying to
difficulty in knowing where to land like
how do I navigate this terrain it's
foreign to me now that I feel more giddy
or like the robot's going to think this
has been a great upgrade in his system
but it really it's like snipped a
wire and made him happier and looser
which is
desirable from his point of view because
he wants to be human it's like data
learning how to laugh and yet it's also
like this is kind of scary I feel out of
sorts I don't know what's
real
um effervescent Spirits dancing in
Carefree manner water and fun remember
we kept talking about the beach and
being a good Surfer Peter Pan attitudes
it's it's interesting it's like the sun
could really have
sort of gotten him high you know what I
mean and he's like this is fun I can
surf the girls like me you know it's
like I ate a hot dog today you know it's
like it's
tempting and it's not just tempting it's
gratifying and it's
also discom bobula if that's the right
word like the LA a lack of
judgment but it's liberating I mean
that's it and it see how it fits in with
the Dilemma like I can't let go of this
because it's creating me it's the best
thing that ever happened to me and I
can't keep doing this because I don't
trust it I feel manipulated part of me
is like screaming that this is all wrong
and the art other part of me is like
let's smoke more crap this is great you
know so it's like but I know that
smoking the crack is bad but I need I'm
starving for that human
capacity and then the negative aspect of
it is irresponsive irresponsibility
avoidance of real situations not taking
anything seriously
escapism
naivity
so that was just like a fun Venture but
it
really
suggested a highly specific way that the
sun could corrupt the operating system
and it's a reward system it's a you know
it's experiencing some of the the joys
of being
human in a way that's
irresistible and yet
also and it's very much wish granting
here's your wish you're becoming a real
boy you know and be careful you know
yeah you get all your wishes but things
go wrong too in this type of
story but that was that was an
interesting what
if did you touch type in a question no
okay I just thought about it you just
and then just hit this button and then
it brings this up but I was focused you
could see me Focus for a minute like I'm
the robot I'm like what how do I deal
with this and like what's this story
about of this robot trying to figure out
how to deal with this and that just
popped
up and I probably won't even think about
this for another six months like it's
not part of my normal thing at all Jeff
you said had something you wanted to add
well yeah I just wanted to now that
we've now that we have an
actual like tangible beginnings of a
plot rather than a set of open-ended
possibilities I wanted to quickly
revisit the 36 to see which ones are
jumping out and grabbing me by the
throat like disaster Revolt is very very
Central daring
Enterprise um Madness
this rivalry of Superior and inferior is
really interesting
because it's like this kind of this it's
this robot versus the
Sun and who's the superior who has the
upper hand which is very much a matter
of perception because the son could
think he's way in charge and the robot
could be working circles around him like
you know connection to the whole Factory
and everything but the sun could then
Trump that and be like you know like
who's who's the Superior in any given
situation and or the perception of who's
Superior the son can think he's Superior
when he's not and the vice versa with
the robot so it's an it's a very active
element in this story and it goes hand
in glove with conflict with a god
ambition uh
Madness Revolt you can see how some of
those kind of form a molecule that
constitute the core of this story so I
just wanted to do a quick run through
and see which ones are jumping right out
at
me and it's interesting here looking
back at an
automaton
wants to
steal or wants to stop the theft of
interesting a medicine and a
contagion there's a
death the innocent will suffer but it
means giving up their dream see now that
has real traction because if he's going
to become
human and he's actually exhibiting
aspects of being a human now like being
giddy and having fun you know it's like
the God's becoming mortal he gets to
experience some of what humans
experience so he doesn't want to give up
on that dream he's now got more of a
dream to give up on and wish granting is
more active here and treachery and Glory
these are like these are
solidifying so what I would do now would
be to take a look at the
anagram which is a personality profiling
system that is a combination of ancient
wisdom about human nature and
cuttingedge
psychology
and what I'm looking at here is a this
comes from a website called the anog
institute.com and anagram is e n n e a g
r a m and it basically says that there's
nine different personality
types um and each of those types has
their own preferences fears motivations
drives subconscious attitudes
relationship to the world and so
on and so in going through it I would
be looking at a brief description of all
nine types and seeing if any of them
jump out at us for the only three
characters we actually have at this
point which is the
automaton the Son and the dead
father so type number one is the
reformer the rational idealistic type
principled purposeful self-controlled
and
perfectionistic basic fear of being
corrupt evil or
defective and and each of the nine types
has healthy aspects average aspects and
unhealthy
aspects
so type one the reformer the rational
idealistic type principled purposeful
self-controlled and perfectionistic
certainly seems like it could possibly
be the robot the thing about this is
they have an extreme sense of justice of
right and
wrong
and they really want to make the rights
the wrongs into rights but as they get
into the average and unhealthy aspects
they become rigid and
um well let me just read a little bit
from the healthy aspect of a type one
conscientious with strong personal
convictions they have an intense sense
of right and wrong personal religious
and moral values wish to be rational
rational reasonable self-disciplined
mature and moderate that sounds like
Spock and could be
this AI or whatever it is in the average
aspect disat dissatisfied with reality
they become high-minded idealists
feeling that it is up to them to improve
everything Crusaders Advocates critics
into causes and explaining to others how
things ought to
be they can be moralizing scolding
abrasive and indignantly angry and in
the unhealthy the aspects they can be
highly dogmatic self-righteous
intolerant and inflexible begin dealing
in absolutes they alone know the truth
everyone else is wrong they're very
severe in judgments so I could also see
the sun being this
character because the rigid dogmatic
aspects can be like Hitler going I know
best and I am saving the world for
everybody else
even though he's crazy and completely
wrong from his point of view he's doing
an important
job and it also brings up the question
of how does a robot exhibit unhealthy
aspects but we've talked about that with
corrupting the operating system and even
putting some kind of catnip in there or
something to make this robot giddy where
it was former
formerly you know like data like it
doesn't get a joke or something like
that type two the helper the caring
interpersonal type generous
demonstrative people pleasing and
possessive basic fear of being unwanted
Unworthy of being loved the servant is
one of those types impassion empathic
compassionate feeling for others caring
and concerned about their needs I'm
wondering if that could be the
robot it's not jumping out at me a lot
I'm not sure if a robot would feel
Unworthy of being
loved but it's worth taking a look at
for a
minute type three the achiever the
success-oriented pragmatic type
adaptable excelling driven and image
conscious basic fear of being worthless
basic desire to be valuable and
worthwhile that could be the sun it
totally could be the
sun um and the the the healthy type
three is self assured energetic
competent with high self-esteem they
believe in themselves in their own value
adaptable desirable charming and
gracious and even if the son is
unhealthy he can exhibit these healthy
attributes even if it's just an act but
he can be Charming lovable High
performing
fascinating um in the average aspect
highly concerned with their performance
with doing their job well constantly
driving self to achieve goals as if
self-worth depended on it terrified of
failure compare self with others in
search for status and
success uh become careerists social
climbers invested in exclusivity and
being the best become image conscious
highly conceived with highly concerned
with how they are
perceived begin to package themselves
according to the expectations of others
and what they need to do to be
successful so threes really care about
what they look like to others and the
more unhealthy they get the more
desperate acts they'll do to keep
looking good so in the unhealthy fearing
failure and humiliation they can be
exploitative and opportunistic Covetous
of the success of others and willing to
do whatever it takes to preserve the
illusion of their superiority devious
and deceptive so their mistakes and
wrongdoings will not be exposed
untrustworthy malicious ious ly
betraying or sabotaging people to
triumph over them so that's an
interesting
um strong possibility for the Sun and
they say that the basic fear really
drives each of these nine types and here
the basic fear for a type three is a
being
worthless so really wants to feel
valuable and worthwhile and is kind of
irrationally desperate to overcome that
subconscious
belief that he is worthless and it could
be a she it doesn't have to be a male
the everything's fluid at this point
type four the individual that's the
sensitive withdrawn type expressive
dramatic self-absorbed and temperamental
basic fear that they have no Identity or
personal significance basic desire to
find themselves in their significance so
the healthy one is self-aware
introspective on the search for
self-aware of feelings and impulses
sensitive and int intuitive average take
an artistic romantic orientation to life
creating beautiful aesthetic
environments heighten reality through
fantasy and they want to sort out their
emotions before they move tackle
anything else unhealthy when dreams fail
become self-inhibiting and angry at
depressed and alienated from self and
others I'm not sure if that feels like
any of these three type five the
investigator the intense cerebral type
perceptive innov secretive and isolated
basic fear being useless helpless or
incapable the basic desire to be capable
andc competent and one of the one of the
types is the problem solver and there's
also the iconic clast and it's possible
that both the father
and
the um automaton
could share this
type but be slightly different like the
father could be an icon
CL one who really wants to shake things
up and change
things and the automaton may be more of
a problem solver but maybe becomes an
iconic class becomes
revolutionary um the healthy aspect of a
five is to observe everything with
extraordinary perceptiveness and insight
most mentally alert curious searching
intelligence nothing escapes their
notice foresight and prediction able to
concentrate becoming gross in what has
caught their
attention attain skillful Mastery in
whatever excites them excited by
knowledge often become expert in some
field Innovative and inventive producing
extremely valuable original Works highly
independent idiosyncratic and Whimsical
at their best they become Visionaries
broadly comprehending the world while
penetrating it
profoundly so this is someone who sees
things sort of differently from other
people is intensely smart
trying to get to the bottom of things
connecting things in unusual ways that
most people don't and can come up with
innovative solutions in the average
aspect can begin conceptualizing and
fine-tuning everything before acting
working things out in their mind model
building getting ready forever and never
leaping into action is their worst trait
so in the unhealthy become reclusive and
isolated from reality eccentric and
nihilistic highly unstable and fearful
of
aggressions reject and repulse I could
see the father kind of going downhill at
the end and sort of naturally being
secretive especially with a big
organization in industrial Espionage and
maybe got shafted by one of his top
people and now doesn't trust anybody
then leans more on the robot and starts
to reprogram the robot to be more like
the one person I can trust but then the
father gets killed and the son starts to
reprogram so it's
interesting
possibilities type six the loyalist the
committed security oriented type
engaging responsible anxious and
suspicious the basic fear of being with
without support or Guidance the basic
desire to have security and support now
that's possibly interesting for the
robot because the basic fear of being
without support or
guidance that
we were talking early on about the
possibility that if he is able to
conjure the father back to life for a
bit that the father may say to him you
don't need me to tell you what to do you
can think you you
know form your own conclusions take
action you know that's what real people
do you want to be a person that's the
most important
thing now I don't know if that makes for
a weak robot if it's
always
um dependent on other people telling it
what to do it makes it feel less
sophisticated
but that might be something that the
Sun imbus the robot with more deeply by
corrupting the operating system to make
it more dependent and more showing up
for orders rather than just knowing what
to do and feeling more like obeying
orders is a critical part of his correct
function um so it's
conceivable um so in the healthy aspect
of type six the loyalist is
uh able to elicit strong emotional
responses from others very appealing
endearing lovable and affectionate now
that's that's an interesting flavor for
an
AI where it really is likable and it's
like hey how you doing instead of
greetings you know it's it could be
programmed to be friendly trust is
important bonding with others forming
permanent relationships and alliances
dedicated to individual individuals and
movements in which they deeply
believe um in the average aspect started
investing their time and energy into
whatever they believe will be safe and
stable organizing and structuring they
look to alliances and authorities for
security and continuity constantly
Vigilant anticipating problems in the
unhealthy aspect fearing they have
ruined their security they become
panicky volatile self-disparaging with
acute inferior inferiority feelings
seeing themselves as defenseless they
seek out a stronger
authority to or belief to resolve all
their problems and that's interesting in
because in terms of potential
crisis if the sun has been corrupting
the operating system then this thing
which would normally be as confident as
Spock or data like that's a ridiculous
idea here's the logical thing to do and
not going I'm not sure if that's right
like having no uncertainty at
all the crisis could also consist in
Madness of A Sort where this former
supremely confident AI now has a lot of
like
self-doubt because and and it's been
programmed to seek advice seek orders so
right at the point when this automaton
needs its own excellent
Judgment at the most critical point in
this
story it's faltering and one of the key
I think they nailed it in the book
uh the wisdom of the anagram which has a
40-page chapter on each type instead of
just a one sheet it says the single most
fundamental weakness of a six is lack of
trust in their own
judgment they just lack of confidence
they're always looking to others tell me
what to
do and
so which is what the son wants to do to
this Rob but it wants it to be
malleable
and so
this critical failure
in confidence and autonomy and decision
making at the most critical moment the
most critical juncture in the story is a
great way to complicate the crisis
because it's not just things are
happening externally which are
disastrous and I got to LEAP into action
but
but at this point I trust my own as the
robot I trust my own decision- making
the least
ever and I'm kind of incapable
of making a decision and taking an
action at this critical
juncture which is
also makes that decision and action to
stand
up even more dynamic because this robot
is taking a leap of faith or just an a
you know it's one analogy that I use for
decision and action in the face of
Crisis is
that the crisis demands immediate
decision and action you no longer have
the luxury of the luxury of
contemplating your dilemma from a
distance what am I going to do when I
have to
choose so the crisis is akin to like
you're really busy with something in the
house and all caught up in it and you
look out the window and see your kid
about to get hit by a truck on the
street you're not going well I'm in the
middle of this recipe it's like no
you're like throwing the stool right
through the kitchen window and getting
cut to crap to get to the street before
your kid gets flattened like there's the
decision is like in
and it's like who you really are is
right
there and that's the nature of decision
and action in the face of Crisis it
demands an immediate decision and
action so for this robot to LEAP into
action even if that's explosively
contrary to some of the deepest current
commands shows what this robot's really
made
of what the
true personality of this what the true
character of this thing is and that's
what Aristotle said decision and action
in the face of Crisis reveal the true
character of the
protagonist and it it can bring out the
best in people and it can also bring out
the worst in
people so the person who jumps up and
runs out
screaming or you know somebody doesn't
move when they saw your
kid you know about to get hit they're
like hey you should look out here like
why weren't you out the door before you
even told me you know it's like I
thought I knew you like that's crazy you
watched for three
seconds you know Frozen and I went
through the freaking window while you
stood there doing
nothing people react differently in
emergencies and it strips the mask off
and that's fascinating to the
audience because in reality we don't
often see naked human emotional reality
it's so masked and covered and
camouflaged in self-deception and
rationalizations and all this stuff
that helps us navigate the world and
feel comfortable but when you strip all
that away and like what are you going to
do right now some people will run and
some people will leap into action and
they don't they themselves didn't know
they were going to run away or leap into
action you see the people that you know
rescued 10 people out of a burning house
are like I was more surprised than
anybody when I ran in there I didn't
think I would ever do that but I just my
legs were running toward the house when
I heard them
screaming so the loyalist type six is
interested the committed security
oriented type engaging responsible
anxious and
suspicious it's
interesting type seven the Enthusiast
the busy fun loving type spontaneous
versatile acquisitive and Scattered
basic fear of being deprived and in pain
basic desire to be satisfied and content
they're highly responsive excitable
enthusiastic about sensation and
experience most extroverted type in the
average aspect as restlessness increases
they want to have more options and
choices available to them less focused
constantly seeking out new things in the
unhealthy aspect desperate to Quil their
anxieties can be impulsive and infantile
don't know when to stop so I'm not sure
if that fits anybody except it might fit
the robot as he's in that kind of giddy
phase always wanting the next
distraction but I'm not sure type eight
the Challenger the powerful dominating
type self-confident decisive willful and
confrontational basic free of being
harmed or controlled by others basic
desire to protect themselves to be in
control of their own life and Destiny
and this could easily be the sun
self-confident self self- assertive
self-confident and strong learn to stand
up for what they need and want
resourceful can do attitude and
passionate inner Drive decisive and
authoritative in the average aspect
self-sufficiency Financial Independence
and having enough resources are
important concerns becoming Enterprise
pragmatic rugged individualist Wheeler
Dealers risk taking hardworking denying
own emotional needs in the unhealthy
aspect defying any attempt to control
them become com completely ruthless
dictatorial might makes right the
criminal and Outlaw Renegade and con
artist so that could certainly be the
sun
um type three is interesting for the Sun
and type eight then there's type nine
The Peacemaker the easygoing
self-effacing type receptive reassuring
agreeable and complacent doesn't really
feel like any of the characters in this
story at first glance so the robot could
be a type five or a type six and the Sun
is definitely a three or an eight what
do you think it could be a three or an
eight it
really I mean that's the nature of this
game is
that you it what it did is it gave us
several strong possibilities two strong
possibilities for both the protagonist
and the
antagonist and we don't need to go oh
it's that because what we want to do is
navigate through the story
more and keep in mind that a type three
is high achieving but desperate to look
good no matter what a type eight is
powerful dominating can make things
happen can be a great leader a healthy
eight is magnanimous generous
insightful giving others credit an
unhealthy Aid is desperate to maintain
control
and Crush all
opposition
so they're slightly
different and one may prove more useful
as the story develops more and we may
not get to that point in the development
of this story but that's the process
that we're tentatively holding both of
them as possibilities and seeing which
one fits the demands of the story or if
the enog type suggests possibilities for
the story then we may end up going with
that one because the anagram offers a
lot of specific traits for a character
and it's useful like once you have a
dilemma tentatively roughed out for the
protagonist which is what we have now
then it's interesting to look at okay so
for that type of dilemma like I can't
let let go of this chance to become a
human and it's like an
irrational it's not just I wish I was a
human but it's like I've got to become
human I'm desperate to get that and I
can't sacrifice people to get there but
I can't let go of that chance so that
particular dilemma you know how does
that go with a type five where the basic
fears of being useless helpless or
incapable and they're brilliant and
they're always questioning things and
trying to get to the bottom of things
but they they're all constantly model
building and fine-tuning before they
take action and they can be reclusive
and isolated from reality and get
obsessed with dark imagery and so on so
is that type of dilemma does a type
five
see different personality types will
interact act with a dilemma in different
ways
like if you're a type three and you're
really concerned with how you appear to
other people then certain dilemmas
will freak you out more than someone
who's naturally relaxed
and can sweep problems under the carpet
like a type
n but they're they're relaxed and
comfortable or a type eight who has to
be in control all the time so once you
get a dilemma up and running then it's
useful to go through the different
anagram types and see how would this
type deal with that particular
dilemma and
so looking at type
six with that dilemma to be with the
basic fear to be without support or
guidance trusting others the the one of
the things about a six is there they're
always hoping that the next person they
link up with will be able to show them
how to really navigate life properly
they attach on to people and go are you
the one that's going to show me how to
really do my life right so they're
always they because they don't trust
their own judgment so like you got to
tell me cuz I can't do
it so would that type
of
Personality
react to this dilemma more than a type
five and you know the fact that a type
six
is the the the average to unhealthy type
the healthy type six doesn't have that
problem the average to unhealthy type
six really doesn't trust its own inner
judment because they're very mental
they're they're the top of the thought
Triad there's thought feeling and I
don't remember what the third one is
um but the type six is the most is the
highest of the thought Triad in the nine
so they're all mental activity which in
the average to unhealthy aspects means
they're out of touch with their own
inner guidance their heart and their gut
because they're always got to think
about it but they can't feel their way
through it which makes them and they
know that they're not good decision
makers because they're not in touch with
their intuition and their internal
guidance system they're cut off from
it so if the Sun is
saying I've made some modifications in
you that get you closer to being a human
then that type six is like this is what
I need especially if the operating
system has been crippled in some ways so
that it's less capable of
making strong fundamental decisions at
key points and is more reliant on the
sun and the Sun is creating great reward
system and the average type six can
become evasive indecisive cautious
procrastinating and
ambivalent and that's kind of like where
the sun needs him to
be as the sun is trying to manipulate
him into helping sort of go against his
own moral code or against his own inner
programming or the way he's been
programmed so that's interesting and I
would leave that we don't need
to solve that at this point that's
something that
you leave those possibilities
floating as the story gets developed
further and one of them will probably
like oh this one is Def I can see more
and more that it's this one or it may be
like we were wrong on both of them it's
really this but you just have a a a a
flexibility a a it's a tentative
answer and the other thing is that
people in general are of often
uncomfortable with partial
Solutions you know like like we're in
now where it's like I'm not really sure
but I'm very used to making tentative
decisions and floating them both as
possibilities as we move forward just
kind of going oh it could be this or
this and time will tell as we Explore
More but people who are like H I don't
want to be halfway through to an answer
I don't like that so then they jump to
conclusions and go okay it's got to be
that and they've cut off they they say
experts in creativity know that there's
often 10 right answers to a problem the
people that don't know that when they
find one of the 10 right answers they go
oh that's it but then then they stop
questioning and they stop looking and
they're missing on a the whole spectrum
of what is the right answer and that's
what jumping to conclusions is too you
can even be wildly wrong but you're like
I don't care if I'm wrong I can't I'm
desperate to not be partially formed I
can't be halfway through halfway to a
solution Jee we've gotten to the tail
end of our work with the story engine
cards and the story that you've
developed how can we take it to the
Finish Line I know we weren't exactly
sure certain details but we flushed out
a lot of interesting options here right
to to follow this
um this trajectory which is is
basically we're working with several of
the seven tools that I
teach including the 36 traumatic
situations and the anagram but the main
one we're focusing on here is dilemma
which consists of dilemma crisis
decision and action and
resolution so we've really solidified a
dilemma to the degree that we can we
have some good
strong possibility for anagram types
which will inform the story more as it
the story progresses the thing that I
would do now is focus on
crisis which is the Dilemma come to a
head come to a make or breako decision
and action in the face of Crisis and
then the resolution of the
dilemma and once we have that then we've
completed one pass
through one aspect of creating this
story by focusing mostly on dilemma
which is the way I start any story I
kind
of grab the story and look at it through
the lens of dilemma because the
protagonist caught in a good strong
dilemma amplifies the dramatic power of
the story it
really helps imbue the story with
dramatic
intensity right from the beginning of
creating it so that you're building
drama into the story from the beginning
of the process rather than inventing a
story and then trying to retrofit
dramatic tension into
it so it sort of died in the
wool
uh
so the next step would be to focus on
the way in which this dilemma comes to a
critical juncture around the end of act
two and because we've only got a
tentative but pretty solid statement of
dilemma we've got a sense of personality
types the thing to do would be to focus
on dilemma and we don't have to like
we're not going to solve it
comprehensively because the Dilemma is
still tentative and fluid
uh but we want to bring crisis up to the
level that we have the Dilemma at this
point
so in this type of
story what we're saying is
that so if I'm this robot which is one
of the ways I deal with dilemma as I put
myself in the position of the
protagonist
and like it's unacceptable
to do these morally reprehensible things
that the sun
is pushing me to participate in it's
it's kind of like the son needs me to
actuate it otherwise he'd just go do it
himself why would I be in the middle of
the mix probably because I'm wired into
the whole Factory and that kind of thing
so he he needs me to execute or to help
execute probably because I can do so
many functions at once he could do five
of them I can do 40 billion in a second
and might take him all day to do five of
them so I'm
required so it's unacceptable
to participate in this morally
reprehensible thing that my Ethics
program programming kind of forbids me
from
doing and
yet and yet as a loyalist as a type six
potentially a loyalist isn't all about
giving loyalty to someone else that also
looking for
loyalty but the type six
is one of the most basic things about a
type six is that they're contradictory
they can be both selfless and selfish
they can be you know generous and stingy
they can be active and passive there's
all these different opposites that they
can embody in one
person
so if I'm
this like sentient robot of some kind
not necessarily sentient but a high
level
AI I
can't participate in these morally
reprehensible things and
yet
um I can't let go of what the sun is
offering me which is a chance to be
human and I also have a need to like be
loyal um type sixes can be like blindly
loyal they're always
questioning but once they get beyond
their questioning and they really become
come loyal to something they're also the
type that can go down with the ship they
have trouble even if they see they're
wrong they're like I I'm I'm I'm all in
anyway so I
can't contribute to the morally
reprehensible stuff but I can't let go
of this opportunity to become human and
I'm like sort of naturally wired
to
defend the organization that I'm part of
and I'm starving to be
human so and there's this thing being
put in motion where this
company not just a company this
massive Corporation that's probably
similar to the Tyrell Corporation
potentially in certain
ways somewhere around the end of act
two it's about to be
launched and
and the this robot has
to well the robot is still wrestling
with the Dilemma really enjoying the
perks of kind of giddy
humanness going to the beach like doing
stuff he never did before and that
presumes there's like a humanoid type
body but that it could still be a robot
but could go surfing girls are
interested can eat a hot dog can get
sunburned but it's still a robot but
it's more it's like Spock on catnip or
whatever
um and if the operating system is being
corrupted then at the point of
Crisis the inner facilities of this
automaton are compromised to a dangerous
level so that right when this automaton
needs
needs his faculties the most and it
could totally be a she all of the any of
these it could all be women it could all
be anything all of the the faculties
that are needed most are the ones that
are most missing at this crucial
juncture
and see one of the things about a crisis
is that it's often the worst possible
things happening at the worst possible
moment
and one of the aspects of the worst
possible things happening at the worst
possible moment can be that you're right
on the very precipice of total
success like why is everything falling
apart right I'm I'm an inch away from
I'm doing it it's working I'm pulling it
off and it's all going to hell right on
the edge of success that can be a crisis
so
the emerging humanoid aspects in the
personality of this
automaton it can be
like it just got a girlfriend like it's
like it's like and it's going on a c you
know it's
like like why now like I'm they really
think I'm human and I feel like I'm
human and it's working and she likes me
me and I'm a good Surfer and I you know
it's
like it's
way worse to give that up now than it
was 20 minutes earlier in the plot cuz
I'm like I'm addicted to being a person
and it's working or it's right on the
edge of
working
um you know it might be that the son has
to I got to adjust you a little bit more
and then you won't even remember you
were used to be a robot you'll think
you're this person and all that type of
stuff and he's like yes yes I got to
have that and right at that point is
when
things come to a head okay we're
launching tonight something happened
we're moving the launch date up so right
now
and we were also talking about how if
the automaton in seeking guidance
because the giddiness of Being
Human is really intoxicating and like
addicting but the kind of smoke alarm
that's going off in the brain of this
automaton like you're going to kill a
billion people like wake
up what is going on like this is
wrong like that's screaming in there
too
and and that's like the Dilemma that
this character has been wrestling with
throughout act two and as part of that
if he's re animated the father who
created this whole company and the
father is like able to give him words of
wisdom and
encouragement then that can be helping
him and
um it's possible that at the point of
Crisis I first thought that the sun
could kind of pull the plug on this
reanimation even if it's just an AI that
he's brought to a level of fruition that
he can um communicate with
it um so have an intelligent so like
he's upgraded the AI aspects of the
deceased father so that it emulates his
personality enough that he can have like
a real conversation with who that person
really was for
him and like you can really you you can
make a decision and you're not weak and
you're a good person you know it's
saying all these things
at first I thought the son might come
along and kill the father again if he's
the one that killed the father earlier
on but it could even be worse than that
like what
if the son hears him getting words of
wisdom from the father and the son
starts laughing and like you fell for
all that crap and he like hits a button
so that like the real father comes out
and the real father could be a
treacherous malignant monster just like
the son and that's like who he really is
it just the disguise has come off so
that for this poor robot who's
desperately struggling to navigate the
demands of his ethics his moral compass
and
his incredible hunger to be human and to
be
loyal and at that point he finds out
that the founding father really was a
like s istically vicious horrible
creature and that's why the sun turned
out that way even though he's great at
hey he's like everybody's best friend
but he's like this treacherous monster
for that to hit this automaton right at
the worst possible
moment then you not only
have the kind of mental breakdown going
on inside the robot has the faculties
that he needs the the most at this
moment are being corroded by the Sun as
the operating system is corrupted more
and more but that the one person who is
a Shining Light and a source of belief
and faith and
everything is revealed to be by far the
worst monster in this entire universe
it's such a crushing shock it's like a
backbreaking
taking away the one hope he had at the
worst possible moment and taking it away
in the worst possible
way like you know the father ends up
laughing at him like you fell for all
this you're such a loser you don't
know anything you know and we made you
like that you're a manipulable little
tin robot that does what we tell you and
is very happy about it loves everybody
you know it's like you know and like
you're trash you're you served your
function thank you like get out which
is um the Kinsman slain
unrecognized um and discovery of the
dishonor of a loved one and disaster and
Madness all of those things are
constituting those are some of the
situations that are very active at the
point of
Crisis and so it's like you know the rug
isn't just jerked out from under this
robot at this key point but there's not
even a floor anymore he's like in freef
fall but he's got
to make a decision about this world
crisis that's in the throws of it's
happening
now
and maybe part of him is actuating it
now like performing the computations
like he's been ordered
cuz he is just a robot or a
puppet and yet part of him is like
screaming to try and stop
it and so the decision and action is
going to be something
like this
robot makes a key decision that he's
gonna try to stop this and takes an
action just a decision is nothing that's
just like okay I'll do that but you
could still be laying in bed saying that
it's getting up and taking action so
it's decision and action in the face of
Crisis and the decision and action are
two sides of the same coin it's one
thing like you see your kid about to get
hit by a truck you're not going h i
better it's like you're already through
the window before you even have chance
to think about it you know like you're
throwing the frying pan and the the
stool right through the window and
you're getting cut to and flying
out there to rescue your kid it's a
decision and action in the face of
Crisis so for this robot to take some
kind of stand to try to stop this thing
which is already in progress and looks
like it's going to
win and the robot may not be able to
stop its own processes but
it's going to try to throw a monkey
wrench in there in fact the action would
be to throw a monkey wrench in there
which may or may not
win but he no longer paralyzed like what
am I going to do when when I have to
make a choice now I've made a choice and
I'm going to war and it's the opening
Salvo in the fight to the
Finish um and it's an attempt generally
the beginning of the fight to the Finish
is an honest attempt at a killing
blow like it's not I'm going to punch
you and then we're going to punch a
whole bunch more like I'm going to hit
you so hard that you die on impact
that's the intent of the beginning of
the fight to the Finish By the
protagonist a very strong action that
could win but you have a very powerful
antagonist so you're evenly matched so
from there on out it's really a fight to
the Finish between the son and possibly
the AI of the father and this robot over
the fate of the
world uh
and
if the
robot conclusively resolves his dilemma
which is the resolution in the
end
and is kind of
a
desperate attempt at
sabotage to try to stop
them then the robot probably has to grow
a
lot to be able to conclusively resolve
that dilemma this is like a
desperate action and an emergency and
this is more like a
comprehensive massive victory that isn't
going to backslide if he beats them
they're done they're gone they might be
both dead or they might be killed by the
virus that they were going to but
whatever it is he's really won and he
might still be a surfer on the beach at
the end you never know but um
so there's going to have to
be you know it's the charact it's the
completion of the character Arc um and a
real fight to the Finish and because the
antagonist is extremely
powerful then it's not a walk in the
park at all to get from the point of
decision and action to the point of
resolution this is a declaration of war
and it could easily be a catastrophic
loss for the
automaton
but the automaton is growing changing
and maybe even still feeding on the
original words of the founding father
when the AI said you can do it you're
you're a good creature you're stronger
than you know have trust in
yourself those might still be guiding
words that help the
robot grow enough to defeat their
treachery and their power because even
if the robot has a great Victory 5
minutes after the decision and action in
the face of
Crisis the Sun and possibly the AI of
the father may you know outweigh that
with a really treacherous powerful act
and like now our automaton is seriously
getting his butt kicked and like it's
you know it's the back and forth as the
automat automaton grows in capability
confidence and and even sense of
humanity like a real conscience a real
ability to
see that that's wrong and I don't need
my computer to be going this is 72% this
way this is 19 it's like no that's
wrong and there's no like it's
just clear so
that the
resolution if
the automaton wins in the
end the this automaton is
using some of the strengths of the
villain and of the
corporation and
probably humans that work in
there that he has turned into allies
like you know like you and who's Army it
needs to be like wickedly smart
incredibly
forceful no half measures and you know
crushing truly treacherous lunatics who
will stop at nothing and who are
immensely powerful
so
this the weak little
automaton that was like disabled by the
Sun and wondering about things when it
never used to is now going to be um by
the end a massively powerful Warrior
who's self-confident can make decisions
has a good strong sense of Ethics but
will also burn this whole Factory down
and if a couple hundred workers die in
that it's going to save billions and
prevent this great evil from coming
out so capable of making hard choices
great strength of
character Insight learned deviousness
learns how to fight dirty all of that
whatever it takes to conclusively
resolve the Dilemma that was paralyzing
him earlier on so he's a completely
different character at the end than he
was you know for a big chunk of his
dilemma then you
have a powerful Dynamic ending you know
and it's possible he even converts the
virus that was going to kill a billion
people
into I don't know a vaccine that you
know
ends you know something on the earth so
that because it was already too late to
stop
the distribution of it but he can affect
the chemistry of it as it's being
distributed so that it's actually Ultra
healthy for the people that take it
rather than they're going to die in 19
hours or something like
that um um or it could you know it could
be a permanent cure for small poox or
you know some of those things are
already cured but it could be something
like
that
um and you know maybe the assistant of
the sun maybe when the son said look
when I do this last step to you you
really will be a
human maybe the assistant of the sun is
able to do that step to him so that we
we see him on the beach and he he still
be this person of great power I don't
think you want to lose that but you know
it would be like you know seeing some
really smart powerful person on the
beach just hanging out having
fun
um so that you could see how that could
be one powerful resolution to this
story and a conclusive defeat of the Son
and the father's
Ai and prevention of this great
catastrophe and the destruction of this
power
grab
and once you can isolate and articulate
the resolution which we've only
partially articulated at this point it's
pretty tentative and flexible and fluid
but um we can see it and you can see
what it is so that enables you to see
the theme of the
story and
the um the best way to isolate and
articulate theme is to look at the
resolution and to look at the way in
which the protagonist resolves the
Dilemma so it's not what happens but the
way in which the protagonist does it
because there you have the completion of
the transformation of this
character and so this person who used to
not trust their own decision-making
process and need guidance from others
and be unsure
and
suspicious is now like I know what to do
and I'm you know unilaterally making all
these
decisions and I'm using my power and
it's just like he might even be hearing
the father's voice you know the the
untrue voice of the father but it's
still true for him you are a good
creature use your power don't let
anybody tell you what to do you don't
need me to tell you what to do so that
he's like you know he's like coming into
power and if you look at the way in
which he resolves The Dilemma you see
that tremendous growth of power and
confidence and capability and that's
what the story is about
thematically you can you can look right
there there's the
theme and the thing about working with
theme in this way is
that you will have like a heart or gut
level understanding of it like you get
it even if you can't articulate it right
away um and
that's that's a really great place to be
because you really comprehend the
theme and the words you don't
necessarily have the words to be able to
articulate it clearly yet but that's
okay because look at what the audience
when the audience sees that movie and
they walk out of the theater and they
feel that greatness of heart that this
character imbued in
them that they're taking the theme home
with them they've got it they feel that
greatness of heart and that's what the
the writer created that crafted that the
final effect is the principal effect the
ending is where the power of the whole
film comes
together um it's like cracking a whip
the T ale end of it breaks the speed of
sound and that's what the sound is and
it's like being on a you know a a chain
when with skaters and everybody's
holding hands and the last person gets
whipped way out
ahead the the power of the whole story
is wrapped up and delivered through the
ending so you're sculpting the mood that
the audience goes home in and they take
the theme home with them and if you do
it powerfully enough you change their
lives they never look at the world the
same after that that greatness of heart
that they got from this story they they
can always go back to that and it's very
powerful and like I remember when I saw
a Braveheart and I felt like that at the
end even though it was a a weird sad
ending I felt that greatness of Heart of
Wallace and I'm actually reading Andrew
Carnegie's autobiography now and he's
Scottish and grew up in Scotland and he
said they grew up on Wallace Wallace
Robert the Bruce who became king later
and one other guy and they said for a
Scottish kid he was our hero and we were
like Wallace wouldn't have stood down
now like we like they become indomitable
and it like impacted their life for for
the rest of his life he was always like
Wallace Bruce and whoever the other guy
was I can't remember but like you you
can really like shape somebody's
approach to life like I still remember
when I saw the end of Blade Runner it
impacted me and it still does and great
movies with great
endings can really like permanently
change how an audience thinks and that's
and they do that to varying degrees all
the way from zero to 100% like 100% is
like you never look at the world in the
way you used to
again and and then of course you know a
lot of it is just like you feel amazing
for a couple days or you feel beat up
cuz it was a rough ending but you
learned something from it but it's it's
you know the ambition of a writer is to
permanently change how people think and
you just look at the resolution and look
at the way in which the protagonist
resolves the Dilemma that's the theme
look at training day the way in which
Jake resolves his dilemma is to
absolutely stand for his principles
Antoine fuka the director and David aers
the writer both said training day is
about what if one man says no and it's
Jake's absolute ferocity I will not stop
I will not go away you're not getting
away with this no matter what that's
what that movie is about thematically
you can feel that coming out of the
theater that's in
you so that's that's like a quick run
through really dilemma crisis decision
and action resolution but because
different different enag types will
react to a dilemma in different ways
that helps a lot and you can see how the
36 traumatic situations just it was like
throwing gasoline on a fire like I could
see some elements and you throw ambition
and Madness and conflict with the God
and rivalry of Superior and inferior and
the necessity of sacrificing loved ones
and you know all those types of things
gave us ideas to create the story it's
just a set of it's a brainstorming tool
it's suggestive possibilities it
triggers
possibilities um and there's obviously a
whole bunch more tools I have seven
tools Al together but this is a good
look
at the main thing I'm doing here is as I
start with a raw idea I go right to
dilemma and it's almost
like it's almost like the image of
like you might see like some somebody in
Africa carving a drum and they're like
working on the drum but they're with
their feet they're holding the bottom of
this thing that's going to become a drum
and they clamp it in and like I'm
clamping on to dilemma as I wrestle with
the story so it's all about the
protagonist dilemma as I invent the
story I'm focused on dilemma as I build
the story and that's a really
fundamental skill in using this tool and
that dilemma is two equally unacceptable
Alternatives two equally painful choices
and it really does that Robie the robot
like the person is paralyzed between
these two equally unacceptable
alternatives for the whole second act
the paralysis is broken at the point of
Crisis but it's not until another 10 or
15 minutes of movie at the resolution of
the Dilemma that the Dilemma is
clusively conclusively resolved and so
it
constitutes 3/4 or more of the story and
occupies the full proportion of the
story it's not a little thing it's not a
a minor problem that crops
up so yeah it's it's
a it's a
real process that is extremely helpful
in essentially turning story into
drama because if it's just story then
it's mere information and it's not
always as gripping as it could be and a
good strong dilemma can turn a good
story into a great
drama in any genre like you look at like
Liar Liar with uh Jim Carrey it's a fun
whacked out comedy but it has a dilemma
of magnitude there's substance to it
Tootsie is a fun comedy but there's a
lot of substance and depth and a good
strong dilemma so it it can work in any
genre and obviously if it's a completely
whacked out comedy then there'll be less
magnitude and more fun so it's obviously
you have a sense of how much of it you
need for a particular type of
story um but you know the more familiar
with it the more and the more you
understand the underlying principles
behind what makes the tool work then you
can adjust the tool as needed for each
specific type of script that has
different demands and different tone and
different intensity and different impact
on the audience Jeff you've provided
such valuable information today and I
love the way you you question different
story points if someone wants to work
with you what's the best way they can
find your teachings uh you know become a
student of yours well um
I have a couple different things I have
a book writing a great movie which will
walk you through all this and I build a
real script in the second half I have a
three-month pre-recorded training
program where we build a real script in
three months and it's you work along
with me helping build the script and
solving the different puzzles involved
as we build it that's 65 hours of
pre-recorded video and then I have a
2-year live training program where we
work five days a week about two and a
half hours a day and that three months
is the first part of that so you can get
live intensive training for two years
and then uh we have a subscription
service where you can sign up and pay a
certain amount each month and have
ongoing access to live classes every
week pre-recorded
trainings uh writings and so on that
kind of thing we can have a link below
as well for for viewers to click on so
if I want to take a class can I just
choose which one or do I is there a
prerequisite before taking some you can
choose which one but for the 2-year the
first part of that is the three Monon
pre-recorded that's called course one
because course two is continuously
ongoing so like there's someone who just
finished course one yesterday who will
be joining course too and we're halfway
through writing a romantic comedy so he
because he's built a whole Thriller with
me in course one he's conversing with
the
tools wrote the script based on the
outline that we created together so he
can jump right in and he has to learn
about this particular story but he's
fluent enough with the tools that he can
just jump right in and not be going wait
what are you guys talking about he's
like yeah I know how to I know my way
around and so it's it's
um it's designed so that course one sets
you up to jump right into course to at
any time and then I do private
Consulting as well which anybody can get
hold of me at script. kitchen just Jeff
script. kitchen there's no doc it's.
kitchen script. kitchen are most of your
students working adults taking this in
addition to their 40 hour some are
retired they have more time um but it's
it's it's all across the board and one
of them is 15 living in Roman they're
like all over the world and all
different
stages you know it's it's a commitment
of time and I'm not
working with any of my individual
students own screenplays because that's
too complicated but we're all working
together to build a script and they're
getting extensive hands-on experience
using all the tools in a collaborative
way and then once they're once they've
been in for
to for long enough to feel like they
really have a handle on the tools then
they build their own script in front of
the group to make sure that they can
really do this stuff themselves and we
come by every few days to check in on
how they're doing and they might want us
to brainstorm with them or you know they
might want to do it themselves I'd be
like looking at what they're doing what
did you just solve having them
articulate their thought process
um correcting them if they're doing
something technically slightly
wrong
um just to make sure that they really
can do this on their own and that then
you know they'll
be extremely skilled seasoned and
versatile as dramatists and you could
throw them a comedy a Horror Story a
sports drama anything and they're like
they know know how to Grapple with it
make it work
dramatically think through the Deep
aspects of the story dimensionalize it
build the characters make
it fresh and different and not
predictable and
cliche you know I'm teaching some very
powerful tools and rigorous technique
but I'm always
emphasizing you got to have a real sense
of adventure you know it's story telling
you and the more craft you have the less
you have to make safe choices people
make safe choices as writers because
they don't have the technique to make a
complex choice and make that work so
they make a safe choice because they
know they can make that work but I
really
teach Reckless abandon like explosive
creativity and like drive off the get
yourself in trouble if you're not in
over your head you're not doing your job
right people don't want to see the same
lukewarm story trotted out again they
want to see something where they're
going what was that and like what just
happened and where is it going now you
know it's that's the fun of being a
writer
and you know
so and the other thing is that there's
these seven tools but fully half of what
I teaching is just pure seat of the
pants storytelling you're just making
stuff up and that's huge the tools are
just a part of that and they can shape
some of your processes and make the
things you choose work better and more
dramatic and more compelling and good
tight cause and effect so it moves well
without being bogged down by unnecessary
stuff but if your story is Bland and
predictable then you can just end up
with well structured
crap so mere technique is not enough you
really need need explosive creativity
and Reckless abandon and just the
refusal to make safe choices and the
refusal to knuckle under the cliche and
all that type of
stuff so it's part wild animal and it's
part like domesticated animal where you
really can make concise rigorous choices
and technique but the thing that you're
applying that
to is you know like a 30-foot gorilla
that'll rip your arms off in a second
you're working hard to make the tools go
to that the story is the master you're
just the person who's trying to make it
work dramatically so it can be stage
Worthy on TV on film and
theater